The art of the cold open is something that's not really that appreciated. You turn the mic on, you start rolling, and you start talking to introduce the show. People think, oh, that's easy. It's not. It involves a lot of time, a lot of thought, and sometimes a little bit of humor, and oftentimes a lot of heart. Well, I didn't have any of that today, but anyway, it's a brand new smart list. A few weeks ago, now it's a few weeks ago, Jason and I went up to Pebble Beach, as you
冷场开场白的艺术其实并没有得到真正的赏识。你打开麦克风，开始录音，然后开始说话来介绍节目。人们会觉得，哦，这很简单。其实不然。它需要大量的时间、很多的思考，有时还需要一点幽默感，而且往往饱含真情实感。好吧，我今天一点都没有这些，不过没关系，这是一个全新的智能精选榜单。几个星期前，现在是几个星期前，正如你所知，贾森和我去了圆石滩。
know, and then you came up with Scotty. Like little angels flying up from … Wait, that's very nice. It was really nice of you to do that. We were so happy to do it. It was very generous of you, and Shawn is very generous. You're a very, very good friend, and you have a very generous spirit. Well, I love you both very much.
你知道，然后你和斯科蒂一起上来了。就像小天使一样从天而降……等等，这太好了。你这么做真是太好了。我们很高兴能去。你太慷慨了，肖恩也非常慷慨。你是一个非常非常好的朋友，而且你有着非常宽广的胸怀。嗯，我非常非常爱你们两个。
We love you very, very much. Well, Will and I were talking about we could both learn something from you. Me more than Will. Well, that's going to be like a seminar. Me more than you meaning that he has more to learn than I do is what he meant. Yeah, no, I think they got it. Wait, Will, are you really that tired still? Dude, oh my God, we got home last night.
我们非常非常爱你们。嗯，威尔和我一直在讨论我们都可以从你身上学到东西。我比威尔学到的更多。嗯，那听起来要开研讨会了。我比你学得多，意思是说他需要学的东西比我多，他是这个意思。对，不，我想他们明白了。等等，威尔，你真的还是那么累吗？老兄，哦天哪，我们昨晚才到家。
Oh, that's right. Well, I saw Jason last night for a few minutes. I feel great. Will's a little more tired than I am because he did a lot more winning than I did. Wait, wait a minute. Let's talk about that. I made the cut. So, Listener, this was a golf tournament, Listener, which I'm not too proud to say.
哦，对哦。好吧，昨晚我见了几分钟贾森。我觉得状态好极了。威尔比我更累一些，因为他赢的次数比我多得多。等等，等一下。我们来聊聊这个。我晋级了。所以，听众朋友们，这是一场高尔夫锦标赛，听众朋友们，对此我并不感到骄傲。
But we are proud that it was to serve all the well-deserving charities up there in the Monterey Peninsula, and a bunch of really great people up there running that thing for years and years and years. And Willie and I did it this year, and Will came in second place in the closest to the whole contest, which was incredible. And then the whole tournament itself, he made what is the coveted thing, which is to make the cut, which means that you're one of the top 25 teams that gets to play the final day.
但我们感到自豪的是，这是为了蒙特利半岛的所有优秀慈善机构出力，那里有一群非常棒的人年复一年地运营着这项赛事。今年我和威利一起参加了，威尔在“迫近洞杯”比赛中获得了第二名，这太不可思议了。然后在整个锦标赛本身中，他取得了梦寐以求的成就，那就是成功晋级，这意味着你是进入决赛日的排名前25位的队伍之一。
Yeah, that's amazing. I guess like pros. No, no, no. It should be noted. Alongside pros. It should be noted. My game is so bad, and I happened to get lucky on the holes that mattered where I could score.
对，这太棒了。我想就像职业选手一样。不，不，不。应该指出的是。与职业选手并肩。应该指出的是。我的球技太烂了，我只是在那些能得分的关键洞上运气好。
Other holes you would have watched and you would have thought, now this guy just stepped. He's never seen a golf club before. He just stepped onto the course. So some of them were so bad. My playing partner, my pro, was the Canadian guy Taylor Pendrez. Swift. What's up, Taylor? Not Taylor Swift.
换作别的洞，你看过之后会觉得，这个家伙刚才踩到这儿了。他以前从来没见过高尔夫球杆。他只是刚刚走上球场。所以有些球打得太离谱了。我的搭档，我的职业球员，是加拿大选手泰勒·彭德瑞斯。斯威夫特。泰勒，最近怎么样？不是泰勒·斯威夫特。
That would have been interesting. Because Taylor ended up doing quite well in the tournament, and I was texting with him afterwards, and we both agreed that I showed him all the shots not to hit so that he could do it. You did provide value. What a great value. But not to do. So he was like, don't do that.
那倒挺有意思的。因为泰勒最后在比赛中表现相当不错，赛后我和他发了短信，我们都一致认为我向他展示了所有不该打出的击球，这样他才能打好。你确实提供了价值。多大的价值啊。但却是反面教材。所以他就像是在说，别那么做。
Don't do what he did. Anyway. But let me ask you something. For as long as you guys were up there golfing, which was an entire week every day, my bad on that. The repetitive motion of golfing, doesn't that wreak havoc on your body every day? Yes. I was tired.
别学他做的那些。不管怎样。不过我要问你们个问题。你们在那儿打高尔夫球的时间那么长，整整一个星期每天都在打，在这方面我可真够笨的。高尔夫这种重复性的动作，难道不会每天对你的身体造成严重摧毁吗？是的。我很累。
Definitely. And I said to Jason when he said, hey, we're going to go up to Sunday before, and we're going to play that day and every day leading up to the tournament, I said, you don't think that's too much. He's like, there's no such thing as enough. This is what we're doing. I'm going to prepare. He's a total.
绝对是的。当贾森说，嘿，我们打算在之前的周日去，然后从那天开始一直到比赛前的每一天都去打球时，我对他说，你不觉得这有点太多了吗。他说，没有“足够”这回事。这就是我们要做的。我要好好准备。他简直是个。
I have addiction issues. That's probably for another podcast. But you can't be addicted to playing golf. He'd be surprised. He'd be surprised. I can find a nice addiction in most things, but fortunately, it's all pointed towards healthy stuff. Yeah.
我有成瘾问题。这大概得留到另一期播客再说了。但你总不能对打高尔夫球上瘾吧。这你可就猜不到了。他绝对猜不到。我在很多事情上都能找到一种很好的瘾头，但幸运的是，这些都指向健康的方向。对。
Nowadays. I actually thought I was like, I don't want to play again. Jason, I was supposed to play Friday. I thought I'm not going to play until Friday. I don't want to even look at my. And then this morning I thought, I did have a good drive on 18 yesterday in the final hole of pebble. I might just go work on that.
如今。我其实当时想的是，我再也不想打球了。贾森，我本来周五要打球的。我想我直到周五都不会再打球了。我甚至都不想看一眼我的。然后今天早上我想，我昨天在圆石滩的最后一洞18号洞确实打出了一杆好球。我可能得去练练那个。
Just to capitalize on that. Did you go get balls today? I almost did. Like a sicko. And I was like, do you, do you, um, when you eat, did you get sick of the food? Wasn't it the same food every single night for an entire week? Wasn't it like eating at a dorm? No, there's really nice restaurants up there.
只是为了巩固那个状态。你今天去拿球了吗？我差点就去了。像个神经病一样。然后我想，你，你，呃，你吃东西的时候，你对那些食物吃腻了吗？难道不是一整个星期每天晚上都吃同样的食物吗？难道不就像在宿舍食堂吃饭一样吗？不，那里的餐馆真的很棒。
Really great folks up there. Yeah. I did take advantage of the opportunity to eat a bunch of things I wouldn't normally find in my home. That's true. It was fun to watch Jason eat. I will say. To watch him eat food.
那里的人非常非常好。对。我确实抓住机会吃了很多平时在家里找不到的东西。确实如此。看着贾森吃东西很有意思。我得这么说。看他吃东西。
Well, you ordered was really fun. Well, before I even hit the table each time, I would, I'd ask the hostess taking us to the table. Do you guys have fried calamari or anything? Remember they go, they go, they go, no, you were there showing them, they go, would you guys like something to drink? And we were like, yeah, we'll get some water and I'll take a diet coke. And Jason goes, yeah.
嗯，你点菜的方式真的很有意思。嗯，每次甚至还没走到桌前，我就，我就会问带我们入座的招待员。你们这儿有炸鱿鱼圈什么的吗？还记得他们说，他们说，他们说，没有，你当时就在那儿向他们展示，他们会问，请问你们想喝点什么？然后我们就说，好吧，我们要点些水，我要一杯健怡可乐。然后贾森说，对。
And if you can find any bread back there, I go, do you want them to put that in a glass with ice? They're getting drink ordinaries asking for bread. There's any sort of carbs, sweet, salty, but then you eat so healthy, these massive salads and then we'll order fried calamari and you're just fucking digging in. This is why I eat healthy. So I can splurge when I really want it. And I know, I know.
如果你能在后面找到任何面包的话，我就会说，你想让他们把它放进加冰的玻璃杯里吗？他们连喝的都还没点呢就开口要面包。只要是碳水化合物就行，甜的、咸的，然后你吃得那么健康，吃那些巨大的沙拉，接着我们点炸鱿鱼圈，你丫就在那儿狼吞虎咽地大吃特吃。这就是我为什么吃得健康的原因。这样我真正想挥霍的时候就可以放纵一下了。我知道，我知道。
It was like a shovel. I know. It's unbelievable. But Sean, we had a nice time and then Jason left early to go get a massage or give a massage. I can't remember which one you said. I remember. Again, another different podcast. Sure, and then we had some dessert, you and Scotty and I had some nice dessert.
就像用铲子铲一样。我知道。这太不可思议了。不过肖恩，我们度过了一段美好的时光，然后贾森早早离开去按摩，或者去给别人按摩。我不记得你当时说的是哪个了。我记得。又是一期不同的播客。当然，然后我们吃了一些甜点，你、斯科蒂和我吃了一些不错的甜点。
Yeah, I ordered extra ice cream on mine and you had the tiramisu. I did. You do love ice cream, right, Sean? And it's not like exotic flavors. It's like you're a vanilla guy, aren't you? That's it. Truly. Just vanilla.
对，我的点了一份双倍冰激凌，你吃的是提拉米苏。我是吃了。肖恩，你真的很喜欢冰激凌，对吧？而且不是那种猎奇的口味。你是个喜欢香草味的人，对吧？就是这样。真的。只要香草味。
Just vanilla. And also for ice cream too, right? Wait, but do you know something? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Wait, but do you know something? I'm not making this up. Do you know why people like the taste of vanilla?
只要香草味。而且冰激凌也是这样，对吧？等等，你知道吗？对不起。对不起。等等，你知道吗？我可不是瞎编的。你知道为什么人们喜欢香草的味道吗？
Oh boy, insert joke. No, no. Because it makes them feel alive. Why is that robot? Because it reminds them of the taste of mother's milk. Huh. Huh. Yeah.
哦天哪，此处应有笑话。不，不。因为这让他们感到自己还活着。机器人为什么会这样？因为它让他们想起了母乳的味道。哈。哈。对。
It's the closest thing to the taste of mother's milk. What, nine out of 10 babies were pulled on this and there's got to be a one-eyed mother joke in there somewhere. We'll work on it. I know. It's the wonder bread of ice cream. To be honest though, so I love ice cream too. If you had, let's just do this before we get to our guest, Jason's your guest today, right?
这最接近母乳的味道。什么，十有八九的婴儿都被调查过，这里面肯定某个地方藏着一个独眼母亲的笑话。我们会想办法的。我知道。这就是冰激凌界的奇迹面包。不过说实话，我也很喜欢冰激凌。如果你有，在我们见到嘉宾之前先做这个吧，贾森是你今天的嘉宾，对吧？
So I'm sure they're waiting. Yeah, it is. Let's tighten it up. What, what do we, what, number one dessert, they go, you get one shot for one dessert for the rest of your life. You only get one more. What is the thing that you're having, Jason? You go first.
所以我确信他们正在等着呢。对，是的。我们说正题吧。什么，我们，什么，第一名甜点，他们说，在你的余生中，你只能选择吃一次甜点，你只有最后这一个机会了。你要吃的是什么，贾森？你先来。
One. Longer. I mean, I'm just surprised myself with cobbler came to my mind. What kind? What kind of cobbler? That's not bad. Warm peach, berry, rhubarb, whatever it is, because I like that crumbly, graham crackery situation.
一个。更长一点。我是说，连我自己都很惊讶，脑子里居然浮现出了水果馅饼。什么类型的？什么类型的水果馅饼？那还不错。温热的桃子味、浆果味、大黄味，不管什么都行，因为我喜欢那种碎碎的、像全麦饼干一样的口感。
Right. So if you had one, okay, cobbler. Okay. Shawnee. Well, you know it already. Just one scoop of vanilla ice cream? Like a massive scoop of ice cream with like Hershey's syrup and whipped cream on it, like a sundae.
对。所以如果你只有一个选择，好吧，水果馅饼。好吧，肖恩尼。嗯，你已经知道了。只要一球香草冰激凌？就像一大球冰激凌，上面浇着好时巧克力糖浆和鲜奶油，就像圣代一样。
Okay, like a sundae. You know, you're trash. You're just trash. You're trash. Okay. Because I was going to say that if that was your last meal, like it was like, like you were about to go before the firing squad and you asked for a scoop of vanilla ice cream, I'd be like, just shoot him now.
好吧，就像圣代一样。你知道吗，你太俗气了。你就是个俗人。你太俗气了。好吧。因为我本想说，如果那是你的最后一餐，就像是，就像你即将面对行刑队，而你要了一球香草冰激凌，我就会说，现在就开枪崩了他吧。
Yeah. Just for the mouth. Right in the mouth. Just shoot him. I think I would take, my thing is I would have, I think would be cake. Yeah. What kind? Like a yellow cake with chocolate frosting.
对。直接打嘴。正中嘴巴。直接开枪吧。我想我会选，我的选择是蛋糕。对。什么类型的？比如带有巧克力糖霜的黄香味蛋糕。
That's all that is. Remember the cake lady? Did the cake lady make you that? The cake lady. She did. She made me a cake. Yeah. That's pretty generic too.
就是那种。还记得做蛋糕的那位女士吗？做蛋糕的那位女士给你做过那个吗？做蛋糕的女士。她做过。她给我做了一个蛋糕。对。那也挺大众化的。
I do love a cobbler though. You know, they also make like a... You can't have any of mine. No, I know. But like an apple brown Betty, have you ever had that before? It's like a cobbler too. It's so good with like... Yeah.
不过我确实很喜欢水果馅饼。你知道，他们还会做一种……你可别想吃我的。不，我知道。但就像苹果布朗贝蒂（Apple Brown Betty）那种，你以前吃过吗？那也很像水果馅饼。配上……真的太好吃了。
Yeah. Anyway. But I can't do warm fruit other than apples. No, no, no, no. Insert joke here, Will. Go ahead. No. You mean...
对。不管怎样。但我除了苹果之外，吃不了别的温热水果。不，不，不，不。威尔，此处应有笑话。请便。不。你是说……
No warm fruit jokes? Well, Mekanose comes to mind. It's filled with warm... In the summertime. They're really kind. They're all in. They're really warm. You're making exception?
没有温热水果的笑话吗？嗯，我想到了麦卡诺斯。里面装满了温热的……在夏天。他们真的很友好。他们全力以赴。它们真的很温热。你在做例外吗？
No, I mean that they have a lot of figs. Yeah. Nice. I get what you've done there. Leave it. Leave it. Leave it. I haven't done a fucking thing.
不，我的意思是他们有很多无花果。对。很好。我懂你刚才话里的意思了。别说了。别说了。别说了。我他妈什么都没做。
You have. You did it. It's like opening pattern, incredible, but something that's even more incredible is... What's that? Yes. Today is... So exciting. Sean?
你做了。你刚刚做了。就像开场白一样不可思议，但更不可思议的是……那是什么？对。今天是……太令人兴奋了。肖恩？
Merch madness. Merch madness. That's short for merchandise, everybody. I love it. And it's a little pun on the basketball tournament. All in one. So you're welcome. And it's for...
周边狂欢节。周边狂欢节。大家注意，这是周边的简称。我太喜欢了。这还是对篮球锦标赛的一个小双关。集所有优点于一身。所以不用谢。而且这是为了……
It's like a two... You think they don't know that? Yeah. Well, sometimes you got to explain it to Tracy. She doesn't understand college basketball or the short term for merchandise. No. The reason we started giving Tracy, like informing her of stuff was because it was all inside showbiz stuff.
这就像一个双关……你以为他们不知道吗？对。嗯，有时候你得向特雷西解释一下。她不懂大学篮球，也不懂周边的简称。不。我们开始给特雷西灌输这些、让她了解情况的原因，是因为这些全都是娱乐圈内部的梗。
Now you're just getting to... You think she doesn't know just basic life stuff? She also doesn't know about college basketball. What are you talking about? She lives in Wisconsin, man. But here's what the listener needs to know. This merch store has got... It's so great.
现在你只是在……你以为她连最基本的日常生活知识都不知道吗？她甚至连大学篮球都不知道。你在说什么呢？她住在威斯康星州，老兄。但听众需要知道的是。这个周边商店里有……太棒了。
It's got smartless t-shirts and phone cases. Joggers. And there are people on there that jog, right? There's joggers. There's sweats. The hats are great. The hats are great. All this stuff is great.
里面有智能精选T恤和手机壳。慢跑裤。而且上面还有慢跑的人，对吧？有慢跑裤。有运动衫。帽子棒极了。帽子太棒了。所有这些东西都很棒。
And it's for the fans that want a piece of us. Well, that sounds gross. They don't like us that much. But if you want some fun... If you're sick and tired of your phone case and you want Sean's dumb-ass face on your phone, go to www.wonderyshop.com slash smartless. By the way, you only said two Ws. You said www.
而且这是为那些想要拥有我们一部分的粉丝准备的。嗯，听起来真恶心。他们没那么喜欢我们。但如果你想要点有趣的……如果你对自己的手机壳感到厌烦，而且想让肖恩那张蠢脸出现在你的手机上，那就去 www.wonderyshop.com/smartless。顺便说一句，你刚才只说了两个W。你说了www.
First of all, nobody says that anymore. But at least if you are going to do it, say all three. There you go. That's World Wide Web. That's short for World Wide Web. Do you know that? Yes, World Wide Web. www.wonderyshop.com slash smartless.
首先，现在没人会这么说了。但至少如果你打算这么说，就把三个W都说出来。这就对了。那是万维网（World Wide Web）。这是万维网的简称。你知道吗？是的，万维网。www.wonderyshop.com/smartless。
Don't need to sing it. Why not? Here we go. Our guest today is a friend, a filmmaker, an innovator, and an actor. I've been lucky enough to work with him a few times. And he is as much fun to work with as he is to hang around with. He's acted in about 50 movies, directed nine movies, made a couple of TV shows, and a couple of children.
不用唱出来。为什么不呢？我们开始吧。我们今天的嘉宾是一位朋友、电影制片人、创新者和演员。我有幸和他合作过几次。和他工作以及和他一起闲逛一样充满乐趣。他演过大约50部电影，导演过9部电影，制作过几部电视节目，还有几个孩子。
And by the way, he's responsible for the best Christmas movie ever and for basically starting Marvel's presence in Hollywood. Please welcome Mr. John Favreau. Get it out here, John. I'm so glad you're still awake. I'm sorry for the long, the long patter up front. That's amazing. I listened to the pod.
顺便说一句，他打造了史上最棒的圣诞电影，并且基本上开启了漫威在好莱坞的存在感。请欢迎乔恩·费儒先生。上台来吧，乔恩。我很高兴你还没睡着。抱歉前面铺垫了那么长时间、说了那么多废话。这太棒了。我听过这个播客。
Are they always that long at the top? Only when you're excited to get into the ring. It's weird. I'm a little starstruck for smartless, even though individually I'm quite comfortable with all of you. Johnny Favreau. Oh my gosh, it's so nice to see you. John, you're so close.
开场白总是这么长吗？只有当你急着想上场时才会这样。这很奇怪。我对智能精选（smartless）节目有点肃然起敬，尽管私底下我对你们每个人都感到非常自在。小约翰尼·费儒。噢天哪，见到你太高兴了。乔恩，你太亲近了。
Bacer, reppin. By the way, I know, listener, you can't see, but there's a baby Yoda on the shelf behind Sean up there. And you didn't do that just for me. No, yeah. He has no idea. He didn't know it was going to be me. Exactly.
巴塞尔，代表。顺便说一句，听众朋友们，我知道你们看不到，但是肖恩身后的架子上放着一个尤达宝宝。你可不是特意为我这么做的吧。不，是的。他完全不知道。他根本不知道来的是我。没错。
Will and I need to clear the decks because Sean's going to take this interview over. He cleans up your Star Wars. Let's get Scotty. Let's get into it. Pull up a chair for Scotty and go ahead, guys. But Johnny, I told you at that last dinner, I think it was like a year ago, I said that how much like, I'm like, you know, I'm so impressed and like beyond, I can't even believe. It's ridiculous.
威尔和我得把场地清空，因为肖恩要接管这次采访了。他来收拾你们的《星球大战》。我们把斯科蒂叫来。我们开始吧。给斯科蒂搬把椅子来，伙计们，你们开始吧。不过小约翰尼，我在上次晚餐时就对你说过，大概是一年前吧，我说我有多么……我是说，你知道，我印象太深刻了，简直超乎想象，我甚至都不敢相信。这太荒谬了。
Like I just think you're amazing. But wait, let's start there. Don't you hate it when people call it baby Yoda? His name's Grogu. No. Like people have lots of different, you know, there's Strider and Aragorn. There's, you know, everybody's got lots of names. So Sean, just because people can enjoy just because they don't know the fucking nerd name
就像我觉得你太棒了。不过等等，我们从这儿开始吧。难道你不讨厌别人把它叫作尤达宝宝吗？他的名字叫格罗古（Grogu）。不。就像人们有很多不同的名字，你知道的，有神行客（Strider）和阿拉贡（Aragorn）。你知道的，每个人都有很多名字。所以肖恩，就因为人们可以享受……就因为他们不知道那个该死的nerd名字……
for the fucking, the puppet. No, but in all fairness, in the beginning it was confusing because people thought it was actually Yoda as a baby and that just threw off the time frame. But it is Yoda as a baby. No. Oh, it's not. It threw off. No, it's not.
给那个该死的布偶。不，但平心而论，一开始这很让人困惑，因为人们以为他真的是婴儿时期的尤达，这直接打乱了时间线。但他的确是婴儿时期的尤达啊。不。哦，并不是。这打乱了。不，它不是。
It's not. Yeah. It's drawn right now. Dress down right now. Gros-goo shows up. Cause this is after return of the Jedi. When Luke Skywalker showed up in the last, fucking episode of men. Cool it.
不是的。是的，现在画风都变了。现在画风降级了。格罗古（Gros-goo）出现了。因为这是在《绝地归来》之后。当卢克·天行者出现在最后一集，他妈的曼达洛人的时候。冷静点。
Cool it. The ladies, the ladies are getting so heated up. Listen. We'll get to flake soon. By the way, fan of flake. I watch every episode of flake and I'm waiting. I sure did. Let's do the flake quiz.
冷静点。女士们，女士们都变得这么激动了。听着。我们很快就会聊到《弗莱克》（Flake）。顺便说一句，我是《弗莱克》的粉丝。我看了《弗莱克》的每一集，而且我在等着。我当然看了。我们来做个《弗莱克》问答吧。
I'm ready. Go, go. I was devoted to that show. And I like the neighborhood too. I know the neighborhood, you really captured Venice. It was like Venice porn. It was Venice porn and we had the great Wally Fister who directed a bunch in this first season
我准备好了。来吧，来吧。我曾经对那个节目非常痴迷。我也很喜欢那个社区。我了解那个社区，你真的把威尼斯（Venice）拍出来了。就像是威尼斯情色片一样。那是威尼斯情色片，我们有伟大的Wally Fister，他在第一季中导演了许多集……
and he set the tone of how it would look. I think it's the most beautiful video. I love that show. I really do. Thanks, man. I really appreciate that. But, so wait, so let's play this dress once for all. I thought it was baby Yoda too.
他确立了视觉风格的基调。我认为这是最美的视频。我真的很喜欢那个节目。我是认真的。谢谢你，老兄。我真的很感激。不过，等等，所以让我们一劳永逸地解决这个争论吧。我以前也以为他是尤达宝宝。
I really did. So what's the deal? It's Grogon? Just got in here. That's the anime show I'm working on, Grogon. No, Grogu is the name as was revealed. He's a baby of the same species as Yoda. Well, that's what I meant.
我真的是这么想的。所以到底是怎么回事？是格罗古（Grogu）？刚来到这里。这是我正在制作的动画节目，格罗古。不，格罗古是他的名字，正如节目中所揭晓的那样。他是与尤达同种族的婴儿。嗯，这就是我的意思。
That's what I meant. Yes, no, no, you're right. You're right in that regard. Did they do like a species reveal? Did they do like a big lift? It was green. We popped the balloon and it was green. Yeah.
这就是我的意思。是的，不，不，你是对的。在这方面你是对的。他们有没有搞什么“物种大揭秘”之类的？有没有搞什么盛大的揭晓仪式？他是绿色的。我们戳破了一个气球，里面是绿色的。对。
Oh my God, there's so many things I can't ask you. What about, I can't just- Let's get into it. So Mandalorian, so before we get into the Marvel stuff, because I want to say, I've wanted to know this too. And I've known you a long time, but I don't know, understand how, because you are, in a lot of ways,
哦天哪，有太多问题我不能问你了。还有什么，我不能只——我们切入正题吧。所以《曼达洛人》，在我们聊漫威的事情之前，因为我想说，我也一直想知道这个。而且我认识你很久了，但我不知道、不理解为什么，因为在很多方面，
this might be controversial. You kind of started the Marvel- I said it in the intro. In a way, right? I directed Iron Man and with Mr. Downey, our mutual friend, all of our mutual friends. That was the first MCU film. Yeah, you and Downey created just a-
这可能会引起争议。你有点开启了漫威——我在开场白里说过了。某种程度上，对吧？我导演了《钢铁侠》，还有我们的共同好友道尼先生，我们所有的共同好友。那是第一部漫威电影宇宙（MCU）电影。对，你和道尼创造了一个——
Marvel. A monster, a BMO, whatever it is. And had you shit the bed on that- It would have been bad. I would, would not be floating today. Telling you, I mean, it is the big balloon that keeps it all- There are a lot of people earning $25, $30 million paychecks, actors who should be calling you and thanking you
漫威。一个庞然大物，一个BMO，不管是什么。如果你当年把那部电影搞砸了——那可就糟了。我今天就不会还在这儿浮头了。我告诉你，这绝对是支撑这一切的大气球——有很多人拿着2500万、3000万美元的薪水，那些演员本该给你打电话、感谢你，
and cutting you a check every month, by the way. You get a muffin basket or anything from- I get muffins. Mrs. Beesley muffins. Downey's of the world, Mrs. Beesley. So, but I want to say, so I want to say, so you're part of that, not just part of it, you help create that whole world, the MCU.
顺便说一句，还应该每月给你开张支票。你有没有收到过什么松饼篮子之类的——我收到过松饼。贝斯利夫人的松饼。道尼他们那些人，贝斯利夫人。所以，但我想说，所以我想说，所以你是其中的一部分，不仅仅是一部分，你帮助创造了整个世界，漫威电影宇宙。
But then, all of a sudden, you're doing the Mandalorian, you're doing all this other stuff, and now you're like creating this, part of this other whole universe. How did that come about, all that stuff? I was doing, so I had done the Marvel film. And how did that-
但随后，突然之间，你正在制作《曼达洛人》，你在做所有这些其他的事情，而现在你就像是在创造这个，属于另一个全新宇宙的一部分。这一切是怎么发生的，所有这些事情？我当时在做，所以我已经拍了那部漫威电影。然后是怎么——
And how did you get chosen or how did you pit, like for Iron Man? For Iron, well, remember back then, it wasn't a big deal, right? It was kind of, it was a little bit like Moneyball, where they were finding undervalued talent. Sure. The utility director, that's important.
你是怎么被选中的，或者你是怎么推销自己的，比如《钢铁侠》？对于《钢铁》，嗯，回想起来，那并不是什么大不了的事，对吧？它有点像《点球成金》（Moneyball），他们当时在寻找被低估的人才。确实。实用型导演，这很重要。
I was a good, I had a good on base average. I was a salty old knuckleballer that knew how to get people out, but I didn't have a sexy heater, right? Am I saying that right, Jason? Yeah, pretty much, yeah. And Downey was your Mickey Hatcher, right? He was the guy, he was again, worked for,
我很好，我的上垒率很高。我是一个经验老到、精于此道的蝴蝶球投手，我知道怎么三振打者，但我没有让人血脉偾张的火球，对吧？我没说错吧，贾森？对，差不多是这样，是的。而道尼就是你的米奇·哈彻（Mickey Hatcher），对吧？他就是那个人，他再次证明了，为了得到这份工作，他也确实全力争取过。真的是这样吗？哦对，对，信不信由你，他实际上不得不通过试读剧本来信服那些人。你还留着那段录带吗？我想它还在外面，我想它是公开的，比如在YouTube上。对，他从第一次开始就太棒了。
wanted the gig, really fought for it too. Did he really? Oh yeah, yeah, he actually had to read, believe it or not, to convince the people. Do you still have that tape? I think it's out there, I think it's public, like it's on YouTube. Yeah, he was amazing from the first time he,
这太明显了。我知道如果我让他来演那个角色，我就定下了整部电影的基调。当然，在他签约之后，所有其他的演员都因为他以及这部电影将要呈现的基调而想要参与进来，因为每个人以前就都是他的超级粉丝。
it was so obvious. And I knew that if I had him in that role, I got the whole tone. And of course, after he signed on, all the other actors wanted to work on this thing because of him and because of the tone of what it was gonna be, because everybody was really a fan of his from way back.
所以我们像拍独立电影一样凑齐了一支出色的演员阵容，我们找到了那种基调，并把它与当时已经足够成熟的CGI技术结合起来，用来制作硬表面特效，比如一套飞行的金属战衣。所以人们真的能看到一些几年前根本无法展现的东西。
And so we pulled together a really great cast, like an independent film, and we found that tone and combined it with the CGI that was, it was CGI was good enough at that point to do hard surfaces, like a metal suit flying. And so people really got to see something that you wouldn't have been able to portray
这一切开始积蓄势头，他们开始以那部电影为基础推出其他系列，一直到《复仇者联盟》。在那之后，我去了，你知道，在那之后我拍了《牛仔和外星人》。我很喜欢那部电影。所以拍完那部之后我又回到了不受欢迎的黑名单里。
a few years before. That all started to build momentum and they started to launch other franchises off of that, leading to the Avengers. And after that, I went, I did, you know, I did Cowboys and Aliens after that. I love that movie. So I was back on the naughty list after that one.
对，但那是你勇敢挑战的另一部令人钦佩的大作，而且我认为你完成得很棒。谢谢。它在票房上表现不佳，你们也知道好莱坞就是这样，他们不喜欢这种事发生。所以当时的我，稍微冷静了一段时间，实际上是通过电影《落魄大厨》（Chef）重新打回了地位。
Yeah, but that was another admirably big swing that you took on and I thought did a great job with. Thank you. It didn't do well at the box office and you know how it is in Hollywood, that's not, they don't like when that happens. So there I was, I cooled off a bit and worked my way back up with the movie Chef, actually.
对，有点让我重回正态。我曾经对你说过，费儒，我记得我当面向你表达过，直到今天我都觉得那部电影有多么伟大。不是“曾经是”，而是“就是”，因为它就存在那儿，那是一部伟大的电影。如果你还没看过约翰·费儒的《落魄大厨》，我恳请你去看一看。真的太棒了。
Yeah, kind of got me back. Which I told you, Favreau, I remember telling you specifically in person how great I think that movie is to this day. Not was is, because it exists and it's a great, that is a great movie. If you haven't seen John Favreau's Chef, I implore you to go see it. It's so good.
太棒了，老兄。对，对。我很感激。真的太棒了。谢谢。这是一部很特别的电影，因为这就像是，我一开始拍的是规模较小的电影，
It's so good, dude. Yeah, yeah. I appreciate that. It's really great. Thank you. And it was a special one, because it was like, like I started off doing smaller films
我会自己编剧、自己出演或者自己导演。后来能继续做那种事，并找到真正能让我充满热情的题材，这种感觉真好。那部电影没有大预算，但以它的成本来看，票房表现真的很好。然后，由于我的视觉特效背景，我最终参与了，
where I would write them and be in them or direct them. And then it was nice to be able to still be able to do that and find something that I could really feel passionate about. That one didn't have a big budget, but it did really well for what it cost. And then I ended up, because of my visual effects background, getting involved with,
我想接下来的一部是《森林王子》（Jungle Book）。那是一部热门大片。然后我才真正开始深入了解CGI和特效的核心技术。一开始我有点后知后觉。我有点回避CGI，主要是因为大多数电影里的CGI都做得很烂。
I think the next thing was Jungle Book. And that was a hit. And then I really started to get under the hood with the CGI and the effects. And I was a bit of a lead-eye in the beginning. I kind of shied away from CGI, mostly because it wasn't done well in most films.
随着我对它了解越来越多，我开始协助改进那些工具，让CGI技术看起来比以往更好。然后在那之后我们拍了《狮子王》。最后。还有你创造的那个，那个墙壁系统。对，为了《曼达洛人》，
And as I learned more and more about it, I started to help innovate the tools to make CGI, I think look better than it had. And then we did Lion King after that. And then eventually. And the thing that you created, the wall thing. Yeah, so for the Mandalorian,
我们创造了实时渲染——在星际，不是星际之门（Stargate）。ILM称之为“舞台工艺”（Stagecraft）。舞台工艺，是的。对。但它基本上就是在视频墙上使用游戏引擎技术并创造视差（parallax），这样你就可以移动摄像机。
we created real-time rendering in- Star, not Stargate. ILM calls it stagecraft. Stagecraft, yes. Right. But it's basically using game engine technology in video walls and creating parallax, so you can move the camera.
背景基本上都是在摄像机内实时捕捉的，而不是事后后期制作。但让肖恩所说的“那个墙壁系统”如此高效的原因是，谢谢你，肖恩，你可以基本上一直朝一个方向拍摄，只需不断更换背景。是这样吗？
And the backgrounds are basically captured in camera instead of after the fact. But what makes it efficient for what Sean calls the wall thing, is that, thank you, Sean, is that you can basically shoot one direction all the time and just keep changing the background. Is that correct?
是的，演员会感觉他们真的身临其境。对，所以这不是绿幕，对吧？所以你可以看到最好的效果。因此演员可以看到背景，但这也能让你，是的，威尔，进行拍摄并像操作电子游戏一样切换背景，所有这些都预先加载在电影屏幕前。
Yes, and the actor feels like they're actually there. Right, so it's not green screen, right? So you could see the best. So the actors could see the background, but it allows you, yeah, Will, to film and just change over like you would with a video game, what the backgrounds are and all that's preloaded in front of a movie screen.
我和塔伊卡（Taika）他们一起制作《我们的旗帜意味着死亡》（Our Flag Means Death）时就用过那个。哦，对，没错。我也觉得那里对海洋的运用非常出色。这就是电影《地心引力》（Gravity）里用的那种技术吗？所以在《地心引力》中，他们使用了一个绝对启发了我们当时做法的系统。它没有全部的视差，
We use that in our flag means death that I did with Tyka and those guys. Oh, yeah, that's right. It was very well used there too, I thought, for the ocean. Is that what they used in Gravity, the movie Gravity? So Gravity, they used a system that definitely inspired what we were doing. It didn't have all the parallax,
但它会通过LED面板产生互动光效，这就是我们用来环绕片场的设备。它们在机器人底座（dolly system）上有独立的面板，这基本上是汽车制造中使用的机器人。所以它们可以移入和移出光源，在宇航员身上产生互动光效。然后当他们把背景放进去时，
but it would create interactive light with LED panels, which is what we surround the set with. They would have individual panels on a botan dolly system, which is basically a robot that was used for car construction. So they could move in and out light sources, creating interactive light on the astronauts. And then when they put the backgrounds in,
互动光效实际上是后期制作中最难的部分。所以阿方索·卡隆（Alfonso Cuarón）想出一个绝妙的系统，我们最终在《森林王子》中也使用了这种面板。所以每个人都在朝着类似的技术迈出一小步。而我们在那方面刚刚取得了重大突破。老兄，这真是，只要听你谈论这些事情，
the interactive light is really the hard part to do in post-production. So Alfonso Cuaran, they came up with a great system that we ended up using panels like that in Jungle Book. So everybody's sort of taking baby steps, but around similar technologies. And we just had a big breakthrough on that. Dude, that is, just hearing you talk about this stuff,
你真是个聪明人。你知道，你就是当代的道格拉斯·特鲁姆普（Douglas Trumbull）。对，学得很快。我的意思是，你成长起来了，你在制作，我的意思是，你在制作独立电影。很多人都是通过你编剧的电影认识你的，显然是《洛杉矶淘金梦》（Swingers），那是史上最伟大的电影之一，
and you're a smart guy. You know, today's Douglas Trumbull. Yeah, quick, quick learner. I mean, you came up, you're making, I mean, you're making independent film. A lot of people got to know you from the film that you wrote, obviously Swingers, which is one of the all time great,
也是至今引用率最高的电影之一。我搬到这里的那年那部电影上映了，整个好莱坞，你知道的，湾区，我简直被惊艳到了，因为你编剧和导演的经历居然同时出现在了银幕上。而且也是从芝加哥来的，对吧？对，我们都是。
one of the most quotable films of all time to this day. I moved here the year that that came out, and it was a whole LA, you know, Bay, I was just like blown away by like me having the experience that you wrote and directed on the screen at the same time. And from Chicago too, right? Yeah, we were both.
来自芝加哥。而且肖恩，因为肖恩太有钱了，他甚至不知道自己有多有钱，但是因为你身上长了这些爪子，你甚至不知道自己是怎么长出这些爪子的。哦天哪。所以，是的，我打算深入挖掘。你全都有。
And from Chicago. And Sean, you're, because Sean's so money, he doesn't even know how money is, but so, because you've got these claws, and you don't even know how you got these claws. Oh my God. So, yeah, I'm going deep. You got it all.
所以，我知道。不管怎样，我们在这里的时候，要向这位在自己领域做到最好的传奇人物致以崇高的敬意。文斯·沃恩（Vince Vaughn）简直是个天才，向他致以热烈的问候。如果你想笑掉大牙，就在文斯·沃恩旁边站上一分钟。对，约翰，我几周前刚和他在《消停控制》（Curb Your Enthusiasm）里合作过。
So, I know. So anyway, while we're here though, big shout out to the man who is the best at what he does. Vince Vaughn is just a genius and a big hello to him. If you want to laugh your fucking face off, stand next to Vince Vaughn for one minute. Yeah, John, I just worked with him like a couple of weeks ago on Curb.
哦，真的吗？对，就有一件非常快的事。我本来希望他能回归的。对。在那部剧里工作是什么感觉？我是他的超级粉丝。他在里面表现也很棒。天哪，我笑得眼泪都快出来了。
Oh, really? Yeah, just one really quick thing. I was hoping he'd be back. Yeah. What's it like to work on that show? I'm such a fan. He's great on it too. My God, it's crying, laughing.
他太搞笑了。几年前我参加过一个慈善活动，最后我坐在文斯旁边，负责运营那个活动的人是个年纪比较大的人，而且他不太擅长主持。文斯一直在我的耳边唠叨，他不停地说，这就是他们挑的门面担当吗？这就是门面担当？
He's so funny. I went to this charity event one a few years ago, and I ended up sitting next to Vince, and the guy who was running it was this sort of older guy, and he was not good at doing it. And Vince was in my ear the whole time, and he kept going, this is the face man that they picked? This is the face man.
我当时笑得眼泪直流。而且他还看着我。你知道吗，费儒。因为他在我耳边说个不停，而我都快笑哭了。不，不，不。但谁会随口说出“门面担当”这种词呢？老兄，他用“门面担当”把我给逗乐了。不过我想回到我最初的那个观点。
And I was crying. And it was looking at me. You know what, faster. Because he's in my ear, and I'm crying. No, no, no. But who even has that term, face man, at the ready? Dude, he killed me with face man. But I want to give that to my original point.
但在我们离开这个话题之前，我最喜欢的贝特曼的表演之一是在文斯·沃恩的电影《疯狂躲避球》（Dodgeball）里。那是你在八号台（Ocho）的时候。当时你还顶着那头假发。你曾经告诉我那只拍了半天？是的，大概拍了半天。这真的是最有趣的经历之一。来，让我们再轮流聊一秒钟。
But before we get off that, one of my favorite Bateman performances is in a Vince Vaughn film in Dodgeball. That's the ocho when you're on the ocho. That was with the hair. And that was like a half day, you told me once? It was, it was about a half day. It is some of the fun. Let me, let's just go around the horn
另一个几乎最搞笑的时刻是，如果人们还没看过，首先，你必须看贝特曼的《疯狂躲避球》。但其次，我去看了一场放映。我甚至主持了一场映后问答，当时还不知道你在里面。但是道尼的电影《老爸的秘密》（Senior），你和道尼在弹钢琴，
just for one more second. Another one of the almost funniest moments that if people have not seen it, first of all, you got to see Bateman in Dodgeball. But second of all, I went to a screening. I actually introed a screening, did a Q&A, and didn't know you were in it. But Downey's film, Senior, you and Downey with the piano,
他在那里穿着皮裤（Lederhosen）唱歌。肖恩，抱歉，我在指着你。肖恩，我不知道你，如果你还没看过的话。那部电影太不可思议了。那绝对是我记忆中看到过最好笑的三分钟电影。但也是一部极其感人的纪录片。当你在那里拿着矿泉水瓶，
with him singing in the later Hosen. Sean, sorry, I'm pointing. Sean, I don't know if you've, if you've not seen it yet. That movie is incredible. It is like the funniest three minutes of film that I could remember seeing. But incredibly moving documentary. When you are there with the water bottles,
像个手里抱满矿泉水瓶却毫无理由的人。那是一部非常严肃的纪录片。然后肖恩进来了，就像哈勃·马克思（Harpo Marx）一样开始大闹特闹。还有弹钢琴的时候，当你在让他重新开始的时候。然后他的父亲，对于那些不知道的人来说，小罗伯特的父亲对这部纪录片的制作方式提出了一些意见。
like arm full of water bottles for no reason. It's just like really serious documentary. And then Sean comes in there and just starts, like Harpo Marx and just starts ripping it up. And the piano, when you tell him to start again. And then his father, just for those who don't know, Robert's father had some input in how this documentary was being made.
他的要求之一就是作为……你弹奏的伴奏是什么曲子，因为你是个出色的钢琴家？你在为他伴奏。那个，那个桥段是什么？那是舒伯特的某首歌剧片段，你知道的，就像一首标准的古典名曲。
And one of his requests is that he sang a certain song in later Hosen as part of, what was the song that you were playing a company? Cause you're a great piano player. And you were accompanying him. What was the, what was the bit? It was Schubert's some opera piece, you know, like a, like a standard classic.
他真的能唱，你也真的会弹。而他就穿着皮裤，旁边站着一个非常严厉苛刻的工头肖恩。那真的是电影中一个美妙的小片段。不过不管怎样，抱歉。抱歉。肖恩，几年前的那个夏天，我们在道尼家吃午饭时，他是不是也在那儿问你这件事的？
And he could really sing and you could really play. And there he is in later Hosen with Sean being a very difficult task master. It's just a wonderful little moment of cinema there. But anyway, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Sean, were we at Darry's for lunch that a couple of summers ago when he asked you to do it?
他只是顺便提了一下。不，是在这个播客上。是在播客里直接——我想也是。你在那儿，对。是的，当时我们都在那儿，然后他是，然后你就说，好吧。然后突然之间你就参与进去了。他说，也许，他说，
He just sort of said. No, it was on this, on the podcast. It was on the podcast right from, that's what I thought. That's where you were, yeah. Yes, we were out there and he was, and then you were like, yeah. And then all of a sudden like you're in the middle of it. And he's like, maybe, and he goes,
也许你应该穿燕尾服，我穿皮裤。然后我说，我不知道发生了什么。我看不懂这部电影。哦，你看起来好像非常自在。你当时是不是说，我们晚点再聊皮裤（later Hosen）？他说，这就是你想出来的梗？难道不是这么发生的吗？
and he goes, maybe you should wear a tuxedo and I'll wear a later Hosen. And I go, I don't understand what's happening. I don't understand this movie. Oh, you look like you were very comfortable. And didn't you say, we'll talk about it later Hosen? And he said, that's how you came up with it? Isn't that how that happened?
然后他笑了，我说，皮裤。皮裤。没错。现在插播一则广告。感谢本杰明·摩尔（Benjamin Moore）对我们的支持。说实话，你们哪位朋友的房子最酷？也许那些配色非常吸引人，嘿，他们很可能是用了本杰明·摩尔的油漆才让房子看起来如此惊艳。你知道，如果你以前装修过的话，我猜。
And he laughed and I said, later Hosen. Later Hosen. Exactly. And now a word from our sponsor. Thank you to Benjamin Moore for their support. Be honest, which of your friends has the coolest house? Perhaps the colors are a huge draw and hey, it's pretty likely they use Benjamin Moore paint
我都经历过。我从零开始建造过一栋房子。我做过重大翻修。我改造过各种东西。我也做过那种事，当时我想要给我的房子换个全新面貌，而我所做的只是自己动手刷了一遍漆。精灵，精灵，对。现在听着，我目前不接外包活儿，但我只是想说我确实干得挺不错的。所以，无论你是想要能唤起平静感的油漆，还是想要带有一点活力、帮你早晨清醒过来的油漆，找本杰明·摩尔就对了。
to help make it look incredible. You know, if you guys have renovated before, I imagine. I've done it all. I've built a home from scratch. I've done major renovations. I've transformed stuff. And I've also done that thing where I wanted to have a whole new look to my house
本杰明·摩尔的油漆只在当地人拥有的商店里出售。在 benjaminmoore.com 上使用优惠码 smartless，购买下一次油漆或样品时即可享受 15% 的折扣。网址是 benjaminmoore.com，优惠码 smartless。本期节目部分内容由 Zippercruder 提供赞助。当我还是个孩子的时候，我有点，我挺像个班级里的活宝。
and all it took was a paint job that I did myself. Elf, elf, yeah. Now look, I'm not for hire right now, but I'm just saying that I did a pretty good job. So whether you want paint that elicits a calming sensation or something with a little more pizzazz to help you wake up in the morning, just look to Benjamin Moore.
你知道的，我精力非常旺盛。我只是总是那种，我猜，有点不一样的人。想要脱颖而出很难，特别是如果你是一个企业主，想要吸引最有才华的人加入你的团队。你看到我在两者之间建立的联系了吗？但 Zippercruder 让这一切变得非常简单。
Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. And you save 15% off your next paint or sample purchase at benjaminmoore.com using code smartless. That's benjaminmoore.com, code smartless. We're brought to you in part by Zippercruder over here at smartless. When I was a kid, I was a bit of a, I was a class clown.
现在你可以在 zippercruder.com/smartless 上免费试用。Zippercruder 是如何帮助你在正确的候选人面前脱颖而出的呢？他们的技术会为你推荐优秀的候选人，你还可以向你的首选目标发送个性化邀请。Zippercruder 还让候选人能轻松申请你的职位。
You know, I had a lot of energy. I was just always kind of, I guess, a little different. And it's tough to stand out, especially if you're a business owner and you want to attract the most talented people to hire on your team. Are you seeing the connection that I'm making here? But Zippercruder makes it very easy.
他们不需要填写冗长的申请表，只需轻轻一点即可申请。为了让你的职位吸引优秀候选人的目光，Zippercruder 还提供诸如“远程办公”、“提供培训”、“急聘”等引人注目的标签。通过 Zippercruder 让你的职位受到最优秀、最聪明候选人的关注。在 Zippercruder 上发布职位的雇主中，有五分之四的人
And right now you can try it for free at zippercruder.com slash smartless. How does Zippercruder help you stand out to the right candidates? Their technology sends you great candidates for your job and you can send a personal invite to your top choices. Zippercruder also makes it easy for candidates to apply to your job.
在第一天内就能获得高质量的候选人。不信你亲自去看看。访问这个专属网址，免费试用 Zippercruder。zippercruder.com/smartless。再次重申，网址是 zippercruder.com/S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。Zippercruder，最聪明的招聘方式。Smartless 节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。
Instead of filling out a lengthy application, they can apply with just one click. To help your job catch the eye of great candidates, Zippercruder also offers attention grabbing labels like remote, training provided, urgent, and more. Get your job noticed by the best and brightest candidates with Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder
了解自己可能是一个终身的过程，特别是考虑到我们一直在成长和改变。我前几天才刚对某个人说，我不是我年轻时那样的那个人了——我姑且这么说吧，虽然我看起来依然非常年轻——但回到过去，我确实不同。我们所有人都在改变。人们总说人是不会改变的。
to get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercruder for free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's Zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. Zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. Smartless is brought to you by BetterHelp.
他们确实会变。我们都会。我们变老了，变得更明智了，或者对某些事情不那么在意了，或者对某些事情更加在意了，但我们都会经历这一切，随着我们经历人生，事物对我们的影响也各不相同。而心理治疗的全部意义就在于加深你的自我意识和理解，因为有时我们并不真正了解。
Getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing and changing. I was just saying to somebody the other day, I'm not the same person I was when I was a younger man, shall I say, I still skew very young, but I'm just back then, I was different. And we all do change. They say people can't change.
了解自己可能是一个终身的过程，尤其是因为我们总是在不断成长和改变。我前几天才刚对某个人说，我不再是年轻时的那个人了，虽然我心态依然很年轻，但我当时确实和现在不同。我们所有人都会变。人们总说江山易改，本性难移。
They do change. We all do. We get older and we get wiser or we care less about things or we care more about things, but we all go through, we're affected by things differently as we go through life. And therapy is all about deepening your self-awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know
其实他们会变，我们都会。随着年龄的增长，我们变得更成熟、更睿智，或者对某些事情不再那么在意，又或者更加在乎，我们都会经历这些。在人生的旅途中，我们受到的种种影响也各不相同。而心理治疗的目的就在于加深你的自我认知和理解，因为有时我们并不自知。
what we want or why we react the way we do until we talk through things. So BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. Therapy really helped me understand these various stages of my life where I was at because sometimes you get stuck.
我们直到通过交谈倾诉，才会明白自己想要什么，或是为什么会有那样的反应。所以BetterHelp为你匹配一位持证治疗师，无论你身在何处，都能带你开启这段自我探索之旅。心理咨询真的帮我理清了人生中陷入停滞的各个阶段。
You have a moment and you have these preconceived notions about who you are and what you should do. And it was only through talking with somebody in therapy that I was able to navigate some trickier waters and come out the other side, but also feeling just kind of freer and able to kind of keep marching on and feeling good. So if you're thinking of starting therapy,
你经历某个时刻，对“我是谁”以及“我该做什么”有着先入为主的观念。正是通过与咨询师的交谈，我才得以涉足一些更棘手的领域并渡过难关，同时也感到更加自由，能够继续昂首阔步，感觉良好。所以如果你正考虑开始心理咨询，
give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible and suited to your schedule. So just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today
不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与一位持证治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。与BetterHelp一起发掘你的潜能。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartlist
to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash smartlist. And now, back to the show. But anyway, so, all right, so John, so you make, but you're, you make like a seminal, independent comedy which people don't really make anymore that has stood the test of time. You did all these things, you were an actor,
即可获得首月九折优惠。网址是BetterHelp，即H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartlist。现在，让我们回到节目中。但不管怎样，好的，约翰，所以你创作了一部具有开创性的独立喜剧，这种喜剧现在人们已经不常拍了，而且经受住了时间的考验。你做过所有这些事，你曾是一名演员，
and then all of a sudden you become a director. And not just a director, but a director who's making films that are very complicated, that using all of these things and all of a sudden you become a director. And not just a director, but a director who's making films that are very complicated, using all these effects.
然后突然之间你成了一名导演。不仅是一位导演，而且是一位制作非常复杂的电影的导演，运用了所有这些元素。突然之间你成了一名导演。不仅是一位导演，而且是一位制作非常复杂的电影的导演，运用了所有这些特效。
And helping develop technology too. And helping develop technology. Like a new George Lucas. That is a whole skill set that you didn't know that you had, that you had to learn on the job. Is that right? It was baby steps up, but I, you know, honestly, I know we've had conversations,
而且还在协助开发技术。而且在协助开发技术。就像一个新的乔治·卢卡斯。这完全是一套你原本不知道自己具备的技能，你必须在工作中边学边干。是这样吗？这是一个循序渐进的过程，但我，老实说，我知道我们聊过，
Bateman and I have had conversations when we started, you know, as Jason was starting to direct. And it's like you learn, what's great about being an actor is it's like the best seat in the house to learn because you get to ask a million questions, you work with these talented people, and you can learn, it's almost like an apprenticeship. If you want to, like you can ask a million questions.
贝特曼和我聊过，当我们开始的时候，你知道的，当杰森开始做导演时。这就好像你在学习，做演员的好处在于，这是学习的最佳席位，因为你可以问无数的问题，你与这些才华横溢的人共事，你可以学习，这几乎就像是一场学徒期。如果你愿意的话，你可以问无数的问题。
I used to be, I started off doing like background work. I think you did too, Sean in Chicago. Absolutely. Mad dog in glory with that. He's back at it. Yeah. Can you go back to it? Is this true passion?
我以前，我一开始是做群众演员的。我想你也是，肖恩，在芝加哥。绝对是的。与他合作的《致命2人组》。他又开始了。是啊。你能回到过去吗？这是真正的热情吗？
He's got his sports fold up chair. You always go back to your first love. Back to basics. I think it's, you gotta stay humble. That's great. Stay humble, good for you. But you know, you sit there and you're watching and they don't let you like close to anything
他带着他的运动折叠椅。你总是会回归初恋。回归基础。我认为，你必须保持谦逊。那太棒了。保持谦逊，真为你高兴。但你知道，你坐在那里看着，他们不让你靠近任何东西
or you know, they keep you in holding and you get to be on the set. It feels like a treat. And then you're like listening to everything everybody's saying and you're watching. And then when I finally got a supporting role on the movie Rudy out of Chicago. Yeah, so great.
或者你知道的，他们把你留在候场区，而你得以置身片场。这感觉像是一种享受。然后你在听每个人说的每一句话，你在观察。然后当我终于在芝加哥拍摄的电影《追梦赤子心》中得到一个配角时。对，太棒了。
Also for applause. Thank you. Thanks listener. And there I started asking questions of the DP and they let me come around the editing room and learn. Did somebody famous shoot that? Didn't somebody famous shoot that? Oliver Wood shot that.
也为掌声鼓掌。谢谢。谢谢听众。就在那里，我开始向摄影指导提问，他们让我进入剪辑室参观学习。是有名的人拍的吗？不是由有名的人拍的吗？奥利弗·伍德拍的。
Well, I'm thinking of something else, but I'm sure he was very good. Great, great, great cinematographer. But you got to kind of see the inside of that movie a little bit. You got to ask questions, I guess is my point. And like I was always super curious. And even like when I moved to,
好吧，我想的是别的，但我确信他非常优秀。非常非常优秀的摄影师。但你可以稍微看到那部电影的内部运作。我的意思是，你可以提问。我总是超级好奇。甚至当我搬到，
first I grew up in New York. I was in Chicago for a while, learning improv. And I finally got to come here on the heels of that role. How old were you and Rudy? Oh, 26, I feel like. Yeah. I feel like I was 30 when Swingers came out. So I was like 20.
我先是在纽约长大。我在芝加哥待了一段时间，学习即兴表演。在那部角色的契机下，我终于来到这里。你拍《追梦赤子心》时多大？哦，我觉得26岁吧。对。我感觉《摇摆者》上映时我30岁。所以我大概20岁。
So I think I moved out here at 26. But yeah. So when you went to Chicago, you were at I.O. You were at Improbable Epic in Chicago with all those people. So you knew a lot of the same people that we know in common who some came out here and some went to New York. And I was washing dishes at Second City.
所以我想我26岁时搬到这里的。但是的。所以当你去芝加哥时，你在IO。你在芝加哥的ImprovOlympic和所有那些人在一起。所以你认识很多我们共同认识的人，其中有些人来到了这里，有些人去了纽约。当时我在第二城喜剧团洗盘子。
So I got to watch all, I got to watch every night Farley on stage. I got to watch great improvisers like Dave Pasquaisy and Tim Meadows. Mike Myers was there when I was there. I was like, it was intimidating. Cause I was like that. Those are just like undiscovered, normal like people.
所以我得以观看所有，我每晚都能看到法利在舞台上表演。我得以观看伟大的即兴演员，比如戴夫·帕斯奎西和蒂姆·梅多斯。迈克·迈尔斯也在我在的那段期间。我当时想，这太吓人了。因为我想，
I was like, wow. It's also a really hard thing to learn. You can watch as much as you want. But if you don't have that little engine inside that doesn't make you any better or worse a person, it's just something you kind of are born with or not, I think. And how early did you know that you had that?
那些只是尚未被发现的、很正常的普通人。我当时想，哇。这也是一件很难学的事情。你可以尽可能多地观看。但如果你体内没有那种小引擎，它不会让你成为更好或更糟的人，这只是一种你生来就有或没有的东西，我认为。你有多早就知道自己有这个？
Cause just in my incredible research on, on Wikipedia. Yeah. It says that there's a Bear Stearns stop for you before any of this. Like, well, so how, when do you transition from interest in the financial world to going to Chicago to chase a dream based on what I'm assuming you knew you may have had inside,
因为根据我在维基百科上做的极其深入的研究。对。上面说在这一切之前，你曾在贝尔斯登停留过。所以，你是何时从对金融世界的兴趣，过渡到去芝加哥追逐梦想的呢？基于我假设你当时就知道自己内心可能拥有的一种，
which is a legend. I like, like, there was no pressure on me. So it was like school plays and that was just fun time for me. And like improv was great. Cause like if, when people went up on their lines, that was the most fun, like when you could be on stage and get out of that. But I never thought it was an option.
那就是传奇。我喜欢，就像，我当时没有任何压力。所以就像学校戏剧，对我来说那是快乐的时光。即兴表演也很棒。因为当人们忘词时，那是最有趣的时候，当你能在舞台上临场发挥并摆脱困境时。但我从未想过这是一个选择。
I got a gig at Bear Stearns cause a friend's father was able to hire an assistant. So I was there for a year before the market crashed in the eighties. And it just, I just got wrapped my head around that I'd have to work a job like this for my whole life. I wasn't enjoying it. And finally I just, I went cross country
我在贝尔斯登找到了一份工作，因为一个朋友的父亲需要雇一个助理。所以在八十年代市场崩盘前，我在那里待了一年。我只是开始意识到，我得一辈子做这样的一份工作。我并不喜欢它。最后我只是，我横跨了整个国家，
and I stopped in Chicago on that trip. It's so brave. And that's when I saw people do an improv in Chicago. I had a friend who was taking classes in IO and at second city and I was like, this is the best. And I was, again, in my twenties, I think I was 22 at the time. And I knew how to bartend and I hit up the people. I had done some volunteer, I volunteered to be on stage.
在那次旅行中我在芝加哥停留。太勇敢了。也就是在那时，我看到人们在芝加哥做即兴表演。我有一个朋友在IO和第二城上课，当时我想，这太棒了。我当时又是在二十多岁，我想我当时22岁。我知道怎么调酒，于是我联系了那些人。我做过一些志愿者，我自愿上台。
And they did the first thing I remember, they interviewed me about my day, right? It was an improv game at IO called the dream where they interview you about what happened that day. And then they improvise in front of you what your nightmare is gonna be like that night based on your advice, right? That's a great idea.
他们做的第一件事我记得，他们采访了我关于我的一天，对吧？那是IO的一个即兴游戏，叫做“梦”，他们采访你那天发生了什么。然后根据你的经历，在现场即兴表演你那天晚上会做怎样的噩梦，对吧？那是个好主意。
So they did that with me and I was, you know, on stage doing an interview, getting some laughs. And then Chris Farley played me as the, so that was my first experience seeing improv. Was Chris Farley playing me and watching them really improvised cause, you know, when you see good improv, you think, oh, is that just shtick? They have up their sleeve, but I know they improvised all
所以他们对我也做了这个，你知道的，我在台上接受采访，博得了一些笑声。然后克里斯·法利扮演我，所以这是我第一次体验即兴表演。是克里斯·法利扮演我，看着他们真正地即兴表演，因为你知道，当你看到好的即兴表演时，你会想，哦，这只是他们胸有成竹的把戏吗？但我知道他们全都是即兴发挥的，
cause it was all coming off of my interview and I was completely flabbergasted. What's funny, John, is that, and you mentioned, and I guess was Del close there around that time? Yeah, yeah, sure, that was Del. Del must have been, yeah. And so you go there because what we all know and people say like, oh, I watched this movie
因为这全都是根据我的采访现场发挥的，我当时彻底惊呆了。有趣的是，约翰，那就是，你提到了，我猜德尔·克洛斯当时在那附近吗？对，对，当然，那是德尔。德尔一定在，是的。所以你去那里是因为我们都知道，人们会说，哦，我看过这部电影，
and they're such great improvisers. It's different. It's different. And people who come from Chicago and people who know what improvising really means that what a herald is and to tell a story and to bring stuff back, it's different from like, when you watch people who are like,
他们是那么棒的即兴演员。这不一样。这不一样。那些来自芝加哥的人，以及懂得即兴表演真正含义的人——什么是先驱（Harold）、如何讲故事以及如何把之前的包袱抖回来——这与你看那些人时是不一样的，
oh, they came up with a different way of saying dick. Like that's not improvising. A different take, yeah. And some people, right, you're absolutely right. And there are some people, like you talk about Vince, like Vince likes nobody as quick as that guy. But you and Vince together, let's not forget about you. You guys are an incredible team with that stuff.
哦，他们想出了另一种说脏话的方式。那可不是即兴表演。另一种演绎，对吧。有些人，对，你说得完全没错。有些人，就像你谈到文斯，文斯就像——没有人像那家伙一样反应敏捷。但你和文斯在一起，咱们别忘了你。你们俩在那方面是一个不可思议的团队。
Yeah, but he's, I just hang on cause he's just so damn fast, you know what I mean? And just hold the reality and be a good straight man. Maybe I gotta laugh here and there. But you see people like him and he came out of Chicago also. But yeah, you're right. If people could improvise like a whole scene, that's different than doing a freebie take where you could get a laugh.
对，但他，我只是紧紧跟上，因为他实在是太快了，你知道我的意思吗？只要稳住现实，做好一个优秀的正经陪衬就行了。也许我在这里或那里能博得一笑。但你会看到像他这样的人，他也是从芝加哥出来的。不过是的，你说得对。如果人们能即兴表演整场戏，那与为了博取笑声而随性发挥是不一样的。
Yeah, where you get a laugh. Kerb does that though, right? They do entire shows, right? Yeah, they have a sort of a basic story. And then they, but I'm talking more like the IO stuff, like all that stuff. And then all the UCB guys did like Amy and Matt and Matt and Ian and Tina and all.
是的，就是那种为了博取笑声的表演。《抑制热情》就是那样的，对吧？他们拍整集的节目，对吧？是的，他们有一个基本的故事。然后他们，但我更多指的是IO那种表演，所有那些东西。然后所有UCB的人，比如艾米、马特、马特、伊恩、蒂娜等等。
And McKay was there when I was there. I mean, Adam McKay is one of the great improvisers on stage. He's funny as hell like people don't know cause he's like a, like a award winning writer director. But those people, but I credit all my like knowledge of writing and directing from doing long form improv because you have to edit, you have to write,
麦凯在我那儿的时候也在。我是说，亚当·麦凯是舞台上最伟大的即兴演员之一。他搞笑得要命，人们不知道这一点，因为他是一个屡获殊荣的编剧兼导演。但那些人，我将我所有的写作和导演知识都归功于长篇即兴表演，因为你必须懂得剪辑、写作，
you have to see patterns and scenes. You have to have callbacks, bring scenes back. And when you first start writing, it's really just like improvising with yourself and using all the rules that you learned around improvisation, heighten and transform, yes and all those things that you learned just to get you through when they stick you on stage at a bar
你必须看到场景中的规律。你必须有回调（callback），把之前的场景带回来。当你刚开始写作时，其实就像是自己在跟自己即兴表演，运用你在即兴表演中学到的一切规则：提升并转化（heighten and transform）、“对，而且”（yes and）以及所有那些能让你撑过难关的技巧，当时他们把你塞进酒吧的舞台上，
and sometimes people don't even know there's going to be a comedy show. And that boy, you really learned how to swim. Yeah. Do you miss it, John? I don't, I really don't. I miss that. I would, I would be scared to come up doing improv now
有时人们甚至不知道那里会有喜剧演出。哦天哪，你真的学会了如何在逆境中求生。对。你怀念它吗，约翰？我不怀念，真的不怀念。我怀念那个。如果现在让我从做即兴表演开始，我会感到害怕，
cause there's like everybody's got phones and everybody. Like there was so much room to fail. Yeah. And in Chicago, there was nobody you could, you know, you just do anything. Yeah, you know, and I feel like there's so much pressure like on a first film, on a first role, people make up their minds about people's skill
因为现在每个人都有手机，每个人都在拍。以前有那么大的空间容许失败。对。而在芝加哥，没有人会，你知道的，你可以随便做任何事。对，你知道的，我觉得现在的压力太大了，无论是第一部电影还是第一个角色，人们仅凭第一次的表现就对人们的技能
and talent based on the first time out, but you have to get things wrong a lot before you get it right. Yeah. But you know, to that point though, you do strike me as somebody who is incredibly courageous and you needn't look any further than probably that move from what on paper was probably
和才华妄下断言，但你必须经历很多次的错误，才能迎来对的一次。对。不过话又说回来，你确实给我留下了这样的印象：你是一个极其勇敢的人，看看你从那个在纸面上来看或许是
a solid predictable way to go in your life, which is going into finance. And then you said, ah, this might not be a great fit. Let me go try driving across the country and stopping in Chicago and seeing if I can accomplish my dreams and talk a little bit about what, cause that's very applicable to anybody listening in any occupation, just kind of listening to yourself
人生中稳妥而又可预测的方向——也就是进入金融界——所做出的那种改变就知道了。然后你说，啊，这可能不太适合我。让我去尝试一下横跨全国，在芝加哥停留，看看我能否实现自己的梦想，并谈谈这背后的经历，因为这对于任何职业、任何倾听这一切的人来说都非常适用——只需倾听你内心的声音，
and tacking left or right based on an instant. And saying, I'm going nowhere here and I'm not going to be happy. As you said, I could see that I'm not going to be happy. I need to make that change. And Jason said, it's brave. Yeah, what do you, were your, did your parents give you a lot of confidence?
并根据一时的冲动向左或向右调整。然后说，我在这里一事无成，我也不会快乐。正如你所说，我能看出我不会快乐。我需要做出改变。杰森说，这很勇敢。是的，你，你的父母给了你很多自信吗？
Did you have, were you born with it or? They kind of pushed me, I lost my mom, I was pretty young. So that definitely affects your whole trajectory. Yeah. So, but I would say that my folks both gave me a sense of confidence. I had a supportive family. Like if I was ever on stage or did something creative,
你有吗，你天生就有吗？他们有点推动了我，我很小的时候就失去了母亲。所以这绝对会影响你整个人生轨迹。对。所以，但我要说的是，我的父母都给了我一种自信感。我有一个支持我的家庭。如果我曾在舞台上或者做过一些有创意的事情，
I was an only child that was very appreciated. Like I never questioned my own, if I had something to offer a value, I always felt everything. You got some out of boys for doing that. Yeah, I did. So I, there's a lot of credit there. And as a parent, you realize how important that is now
我是个独生子，这非常受到赏识。就像我从未质疑过自己，如果我有任何有价值的东西可以提供，我总是能感受到一切。你因为那样做而得到了不少夸奖。是的，我得到了。所以，这里面有很多功劳。作为一个父母，你现在意识到这有多么重要，
and with your kids to do it, because that's their foundation, right? That's like, that gives them their base and their stability cause they're going to hit headwinds and there's going to be a lot of things telling them they're not doing the right thing. And if they go down to deep memories and they have a sense of worth and confidence,
对你的孩子这样做，因为那是他们的地基，对吧？那是赋予他们基础和稳定性的东西，因为他们将遭遇逆风，会有很多声音告诉他们做得不对。如果他们能够回溯深刻的记忆，并且拥有价值感和自信，
I think that gets them through a lot of, gives them a good keel. Yeah, yeah. Right? So, so there's that. But then there's also like just realizing, cause I was, on the other hand, it was like I was not really permitted to study things
我想这能帮他们度过很多难关，让他们保持良好的心态。是的，是的。对吧？所以，有这方面的原因。但另一方面，这也是因为我意识到，因为我，
in school that weren't academic. I was pushed towards academics away from like, there are high schools in New York, like performing arts and stuff and art and design. And, you know, where it would have been fun, I would have liked to have done that. My folks were no, go into the sciences and you have to pick a pragmatic course
在学校里其实不被允许学习非学术类的东西。我被推向学术界，远离那些比如纽约有表演艺术之类的学校，还有艺术与设计学校。你知道的，如果去那里会很有趣，我其实挺想去的。我的父母说“不”，去学科学吧，你必须选择一门务实的课程，
so that you have stability. We didn't come from, you know, we didn't have a lot of dough. So you had to pick a career where you could have some stability. But then finally, like, and so all my associations with play was like after school, taking an elective in college. Like it was all positive. I never felt pressure.
这样你才有稳定性。我们没有，你知道的，我们没有很多钱。所以你必须选择一个能让你获得一些稳定性的职业。但最后，所以，我对“玩耍”的所有联想，都像是放学后，在大学里选修一门选修课。这一切都是积极的。我从未感到压力。
It was always play time for me. So when it came time for me to write or do sketch comedy, it was all fun. I felt people who picked the career earlier felt a lot of pressure. I don't know what it was like, Jason, because I know you were at it, you were a pro from the beginning.
对我来说，那一直是游戏时间。所以当轮到我写作或做小品喜剧时，这一切都是好玩的。我觉得那些更早选择职业的人感到了很大的压力。我不知道那是什么感觉，杰森，因为我知道你一直都在做，你从一开始就是个专业人士。
But I never felt like there was, that I had to compete in any way. Anything I was doing was just a lark and my family got a kick out of it. Jason once told me, you told me this when you were like 12 years old and you had a scene, right? In Little House in the Prairie,
但我从未觉得有什么，我有必要以任何方式去竞争。我所做的任何事都只是一场玩笑，我的家人也从中得到了乐趣。杰森曾经告诉我，你以前告诉我这个，当时你大概12岁，你有一场戏，对吧？在《草原小屋》里，
you had to cry and you weren't doing it. And your dad whispered in your ear and he said, if you don't cry in this scene, we don't eat tonight. You're right. No, I like that. Did he say that? Yeah, I said that. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
你必须哭，但你哭不出来。你爸爸在你耳边低声说，如果你在这场戏里不哭，我们今晚就没饭吃。你说得对。不，我喜欢这个。他真的这么说吗？是的，我这么说了。对，对，对。
We don't eat tonight. Right, I wrote it on the inside of my wrist. It's still there today. Wrote it down. I hope that's a joke. So, John, so first of all, what part of, did you grew up in this city? Did you grew up on Long Island?
今晚没饭吃。没错，我把它写在手腕内侧了。直到今天它还在那里。写了下来。我希望那是个玩笑。所以，约翰，首先，你是哪个部分的？你是在这座城市长大的吗？你是在长岛长大的吗？
No, Queens. I was a Queens guy. Oh, you were in Queens, okay, great. Plushing. So, yeah, right near the Trump wing of that. What's that? I moved around. Yeah, Queens hasn't had a good showing in the last.
不，皇后区。我是个皇后区人。哦，你在皇后区，太好了。法拉盛。所以，是的，就在那个川普飞地附近。什么？我搬过家。是的，皇后区在过去表现得可不太好。
Anyway, so you grew up in Queens. Paul Simon. Paul Simon. There we go. Paul Simon, Ray Romano. Ray Romano. We love Ray Romano. Yes, that's right.
不管怎样，你在皇后区长大。保罗·西蒙。保罗·西蒙。这就对了。保罗·西蒙，雷·罗马诺。雷·罗马诺。我们爱雷·罗马诺。是的，没错。
Yes, we do. So, anyway, so you move out to New York. You do the Bear Stearns thing. So now you're there, you're... Oh, I didn't move to New York. I was commuting for Queens. You're in New York. I mean, you went from Queens to Chicago is what it means.
是的，我们爱。所以，不管怎样，你搬到了纽约。你做了贝尔斯登的工作。所以现在你在那里，你……哦，我没有搬到纽约。我是从皇后区通勤的。你在纽约。我的意思是，意思是你是从皇后区去到芝加哥的。
The fantasy is you moved to the city, but no, that was not my life. That never happened. When you skipped it, you just went to Chicago. I was like Tony Monero. I was taking the bridge. Bridge and tunnel. Right, just like Saturday Night in Fever.
幻想中是你搬到了城市里，但并没有，那不是我的生活。那从未发生过。当你跳过它时，你直接去了芝加哥。我当时就像托尼·马内罗。我在过桥。桥梁与隧道。没错，就像《周末夜狂热》一样。
So you go out to Chicago. You start working at Second City in I.O. And you're doing all this stuff. And that's when I was like, now I'm doing what I love to do. That's when my life kicked into gear. Like it was all gravy at that point. I was working, seating people and washing dishes
所以你去了芝加哥。你开始在第二城和IO工作。你做着所有这些事情。也就是在那时，我心想，现在我在做我热爱的事了。那是我的生活开始步入正轨的时候。到那个时候，一切都是赚来的。我在工作，在第二城引导客人入座、洗盘子，
at Second City and selling t-shirts there and doing... And your dad, you're checking in with your dad and your dad's like, how's it going? And you're like, I'm killing it. He loved it too. He loved it. Like he was all into it too.
在那里卖T恤，还做着……而你的爸爸，你当时跟爸爸保持联系，你爸爸问，情况怎么样？而你说，我简直棒极了。他也喜欢这样。他很喜欢。他对此也全情投入。
And my dad was great because he was like, he's like, look, he says, you're 22. When I called him from Chicago, I'm like, I think I want to do this. After that show I saw, he says, you know what? You're old enough to know, like to make a responsible decision, but you're young enough that if you're wrong,
我爸爸太棒了，因为他说，他看着我说，你看，你22岁了。当我从芝加哥打电话给他时，我说，我想我想要做这个。在我看了那场演出之后，他说，你知道吗？你已经足够成熟，可以做出一个负责任的决定，但你还足够年轻，即使你错了，
you could still do something else. That's awesome. And so that was a permission that I got. And I really embraced it. What a great thing to say to your kid who calls excited about something. That is so fucking great. So I love that.
你仍然可以去做别的事情。这太棒了。所以那是给予我的许可。我真的欣然接受了。对一个兴奋地给家里打电话的孩子说出这样的话，是多么好的一件事啊。这真是太棒了。所以我很喜欢这个。
How does it come about that you write swingers? What was that? That was also my dad, I would say, because he gave me a copy of Final Draft. The writing software. I'm not sponsored in any way, but I have to say it's a podcast. Wait, you just got a free update. You just got a free update.
你是怎么开始写《摇摆者》的？那是怎么回事？那也是因为我爸爸，我会这么说，因为他给了我一份Final Draft的副本。剧本写作软件。我没有受到任何赞助，但我必须说它是个播客。等等，你刚得到了一次免费升级。你刚得到了一次免费升级。
Trace, if you want to write a script, there's a formatting piece of software that where you can type in dialogue, it comes out looking like a script. But that's really it, because you start writing. You want to send Jason a script, you got it. Sorry.
Trace，如果你想写剧本，有一个格式化软件，你可以在里面输入对话，写出来看起来就像个剧本。但真的也就这样了，因为你开始写作。你想给杰森发个剧本，你拿到了。抱歉。
You know, you start typing and it formats it. And I had read a lot of scripts because I was acting, right? Because I had come out here on the heels of Rudy, which was, by the way, to get a role like I got in Rudy out of Chicago, that was like a home run. So rare, though, Tim. So rare, because they were shooting local
你知道，你开始打字，它就会自动排版。我读过很多剧本因为我在演戏，对吧？因为我是借着《追梦赤子心》的热度来到这里的，顺便说一句，能从芝加哥得到我在《追梦赤子心》里那样的角色，简直就像是一记本垒打。蒂姆，但太罕见了。太罕见了，因为他们是在当地拍摄，
and they were looking for local talent to say something. And you just auditioned for it in Chicago. Yeah, yeah. And I improvved a lot in the audition and David Anspa and Angela Pizzo, the director and the writer. But so many actors, because I was there too at that time,
而且他们在寻找当地的演员来台词。你只是在芝加哥为它试镜。对，对。我在试镜时即兴发挥了很多，大卫·安斯派和安吉拉·皮佐，导演和编剧。但有那么多演员——因为我当时也在那儿——
so many actors would scramble and just like kill for one of those roles of the movies that came through Chicago, because there were so few, unless it was a John Hughes film. You have the John Hughes movies, because I was just about to say, and I was an extra on a lot of John Hughes movies.
那么多演员会争先恐后地为那些路过芝加哥拍摄的电影角色拼命，因为这样的机会太少了，除非那是约翰·休斯的电影。你有约翰·休斯的电影，因为我正要说，我曾是许多约翰·休斯电影的群众演员。
You know? I love that. Really? Yeah, yeah. That's cool. Yeah, I got called back for, what's that Sandy Bullock movie? While You Were Sleeping.
你知道吗？我喜欢那样。真的吗？是的，是的。太酷了。是的，我接到过回调通知，是那部桑德拉·布洛克的电影叫什么来着？《二见钟情》。
While You Were Sleeping. Yeah, it was in Orderly. I was still waiting to hear if I got it. No, yeah. No. Huh. Well. Good story.
《二见钟情》。是的，演一个杂役。我还在等消息看我有没有被选上。没有，是的。没有。哈。好吧。好故事。
So, thanks for interrupting John. Sorry. So, you get Rudy, you get cast out of Chicago. Move out of here, get an agent. Get an agent. The producers from that say when you come out, if you come out to LA,
所以，谢谢你打断约翰。抱歉。所以，你得到了《追梦赤子心》，你从芝加哥被选中。搬到这里，找个经纪人。找个经纪人。那里的制片人说当你来的时候，如果你来洛杉矶，
because I thought it was like, what they would do, Sean, if you remember, is people would work and live in Chicago, and then they'd come out here for like pilot season. That's right. Same as New York. We would do it too.
因为我以为，肖恩，如果你还记得的话，他们会做的是，人们在芝加哥工作和生活，然后他们来这里参加试镜季。没错。纽约也一样。我们也会这么做。
We would come out for two months. But when I came out, they were like, okay, you gotta tell everybody you really live here. Otherwise, they're not gonna wanna. And then next thing you know is like, oh no, you really do have to move out here. Right.
我们会来两个月。但当我来的时候，他们说，好吧，你得告诉所有人你真的住在这里。否则他们不会愿意。然后接下来你知道的就是，哦不，你真的必须搬到这里来。对。
So, it was like, I didn't realize I was moving out there. And so, I would read a lot of scripts and audition a lot. So, I had enough heat off of that movie before it came out that I was getting to go to auditions. And when you go to auditions, you read a lot of scripts.
所以，就像是，我没意识到我要搬到那里。因此，我会读很多剧本并参加很多试镜。所以在那部电影上映前，我借着那股热度得到了很多试镜的机会。当你去试镜时，你会读很多剧本。
And also, I would improv a lot. Because I was usually like the comedic supporting friend. And so, they loved if I threw in some jokes and punched up their stuff. And then, when I got the final draft program, I just started writing. And next thing you know, you get like four pages. And now, I'm writing about me and inspired by my friends
而且，我经常即兴表演。因为我通常扮演搞笑的配角朋友。所以他们很喜欢我加入一些笑话，并为他们的内容增色。然后，当我拿到Final Draft程序时，我开始写作。接下来你知道的，你写了大约四页。现在，我开始写关于我自己以及受我的朋友们启发的创作，
and what we would do hanging out. And there was like- And were you buddies with Vince at the time? Yeah, I met him on Rudy. Yeah, okay. I met him on Rudy. And he moved out to LA roughly the same time, maybe? He was out here already.
还有我们闲逛时会做的事。当时有——而且你当时和文斯是好朋友吗？对，我在《追梦赤子心》上认识他的。对，好吧。我在《追梦赤子心》上认识他的。他大约在差不多的时间搬到洛杉矶的吗，也许？他当时已经在这里了。
So, it was a lot like the movie where he was showing me around and showing me the ropes. And here's where you hang out. And we go to Vegas and stuff like that. So, it was very much inspired by, it's his, and everything he says in the movie, even if I wrote it, it was based on conversations that we had had
所以这很像那部电影，他在那里带我四处参观，带我了解门路。这是你闲逛的地方。我们去拉斯维加斯之类的。所以这很大程度上受到他的启发，这是他的，他在电影中所说的一切，即使是我写的，也是基于我们曾有过的对话，
or things that he would say, exaggerations of it. But it was really channeling his humor and everything that he's, how entertaining as Will points out, how he is just as a naturally as a person. And he was reading for roles that were, he's a good looking dude. So, he was reading for all of these like either leads
或者是他会说的话，是这些话的夸张版。但它真的是在引导他的幽默感，以及他所拥有的一切，正如威尔所指出的，他是多么具有娱乐精神，作为一个人的天性。他当时在为一些角色试镜，他是个长相不错的家伙。所以他在为所有这些主角试镜，
or the, you know, the enemy of the lead. Or, you know, he was always playing those kind of, they saw his face and didn't realize how funny he was. And so, this was the first time he really got to be who he was, I think, on camera. You know, I tell you, John, one of the scenes that I love about, and I think it's not unheralded, but in, in swingers,
或者是，你知道的，主角的死对头。或者，你知道的，他总是扮演那种角色，他们看到他的脸，却没有意识到他是多么有趣。所以这是他第一次真正能够在镜头前做他自己，我想。你知道我告诉你，约翰，在《摇摆者》中我最喜欢的一场戏，而且我认为这并不是不为人知，
is the moment when you guys are at the former 101 restaurant. Cafe 101. Cafe 101. It was right at the corner of Franco. And it wasn't even that then. So, there's that scene and you guys are talking. And he's looking over your shoulder and he's like, oh, she's a little baby.
就是你们在以前的101餐厅的那场戏。101咖啡馆。101咖啡馆。它就在弗兰科的街角。那时候甚至还不是那样。所以有那么一场戏，你们在聊天。他看着你的肩膀说，哦，她是个小宝贝。
Oh, and he starts, he thinks he's, the woman is making eyes at him and waving. He's like, she's playing a little game. She's like, he's doing, he's waving back at her. And then it turns out she has a little kid. She's got a baby across from her. And that is based on something that really happened to Vince.
哦，他开始，他以为他，那个女人在向他抛媚眼并挥手。他说，她在玩一个小游戏。他说，他在向她挥手回应。然后结果发现她有个小孩。她对面坐着个婴儿。那是基于发生在文斯身上的真实事情。
No way. In an airport. No way. Yes. Somebody was waving at him. Somebody was waving at him and making faces. And he was very off put by it. And then finally they picked up a baby.
不会吧。在机场。不会吧。是的。有人在向他挥手。有人在向他挥手并做鬼脸。他对此感到非常反感。然后最后他们抱起了一个婴儿。
Because you know how airports have the seats in the rows? And that's so funny. So that was a, you'll have to ask him about that. But what's so great about it is it's kind of, it's kind of tragic in that moment. It's at the end of the movie and there's sort of a tragedy to it. It reminds me a lot of, you know, one of my favorite,
因为你知道机场的座位都是一排排的吗？太搞笑了。所以那是，你得去问问他这件事。但最棒的是，那一刻有点，那一刻有点悲剧色彩。那是在电影的结尾，其中内置了一种悲剧性。这让我想起很多，你知道的，我和尼尔最喜欢的，
my favorite film of all time with Neil and I, there's this kind of tragedy to it that's built in. And I think that there's that there in that moment. It worked nice because it was like, you know, it's, he found somebody, Mikey found somebody who he really connected with. And now he wasn't on that journey anymore. He was ready to, you know.
我们有史以来最喜欢的电影，其中内置了这种悲剧性。我认为那一刻也有这种感觉。它效果很好，因为就像，你知道的，他找到了某人，迈克找到了一个真正有共鸣的人。现在他不再处于那段旅程中了。他准备好去，你知道的。
So I think in that way, there's sort of a disconnect that happens there. Maybe, I don't know, you know, it's not like you think about the stuff when you write it. It was honestly like him telling me the funniest thing just happened to me at the airport. And then I worked it into the script. Right, and you don't really think about this.
所以我觉得在那种情况下，那里发生了一种脱节。也许吧，我不知道，你知道的，你写的时候不会去想这些东西。老实说，这只是他告诉我“刚刚在机场发生了最搞笑的事”。然后我把它写进剧本里了。没错，你其实并没有去想这些。
You're not deliberate or strategic about what it is you put into your stuff. You're just kind of putting in, whether it would be writing, acting or directing or producing stuff that resonates with you. It is your own personal taste. And you've learned how to use more and more and more tools that you're disposal as a director
你对你放进作品里的东西并不是深思熟虑或充满战略性的。你只是在投入，无论是写作、表演、导演还是制作那些能与你产生共鸣的东西。这完全是你的个人品味。而且你已经学会了作为一名导演如何使用越来越多唾手可得的工具
to communicate that. You're absolutely right. And it's not conscious in any way, you know, and you learn to go to things that interest you or that you are drawn to, but you're making instinctive, seemingly instinctive choices. But that doesn't mean that they're not valid. It's just that your conscious mind isn't doing it.
来传达这一点。你说得完全对，这在任何方面都不是有意识的，你知道的，你会学会去关注那些让你感兴趣或吸引你的事情，但你做出的是本能的、看似本能的选择。但这并不意味着它们无效。只是你的意识没有参与其中。
It's coming from a deeper place. And so a lot of the writing you do or images you're drawn to, you might not even understand why they resonate, but you're really working through things subconsciously, I think, and that's one of the great gifts of being able to do what we do as a career is that you're really working through stuff
它来自一个更深层的地方。所以你写的很多东西或者吸引你的影像，你甚至可能不明白它们为什么会产生共鸣，但我认为你真的在潜意识里处理一些事情，这也是作为一名导演能够将我们所做的事情作为职业的伟大天赋之一，那就是你真的在处理一些事情，
usually from a younger age. But I will say, and not to embarrass you with a compliment, but your ability to bring the Favreau sensibility to what has become the industry-saving genre was something that I think folks will look back on as a real gift, because had somebody without your sensibility, comedically, you know,
通常是从年轻时就开始了。但我必须说，并不是为了用恭维让你尴尬，但你能够将费儒的敏感度带到这个已经成为拯救行业类型的领域中去，我认为人们回过头来看时会认为这是一份真正的天赋，因为如果没有一个在喜剧上具备你那样敏感度的人，你知道的，
your sense of humanity, vulnerability, blah, blah, blah, to infuse that into a superhero comic book genre is, would never be expected. But your ability to kind of trojan-horse that in there, I mean, I guess that's my question. How much of that was part of your pitch as a director when you talked to The Powers It Be? Was it Kevin at the time?
你的那种人情味、脆弱感等等，将这些融入超级英雄漫画类型中，是从来不会被预料到的。但你能够将这一点“特洛伊木马式”地塞进去，我的意思是，这大概是我的问题。当你与当权者交谈时，作为导演，这在你的推介中占了多大比重？当时是凯文吗？
I think what was cool about, here's what's interesting. So I work on Elf, right? And with Elf. You haven't even got to Elf yet. Exactly, I'm gonna spend some time with that. But that was what came before, right? That was sort of my hit that got me as a director. That's the first thing that I did that made.
我认为很酷的是，这里有趣的是。所以我在拍《精灵总动员》，对吧？《精灵总动员》。你还没聊到《精灵总动员》呢。没错，我要花点时间聊聊那部。但那是之前拍的，对吧？那是作为导演让我成名的热门之作。那是我的第一部作品，让……
20 years ago. 20 years ago. So well-deserved. And what's interesting to me is when you do a comedy, everybody's giving you a million notes about every joke, right? But they didn't care about any of the action stuff. Not one note about like the Slay Chase
20年前。20年前。实至名归。而让我感兴趣的是，当你拍一部喜剧时，每个人都会对每一个笑话给你提出数百万条意见，对吧？但他们对任何动作戏都不在意。关于雪橇追逐戏没有一条意见，
or any of that stuff. When I went to Marvel, all they gave me notes on was my storyboards around the action sequences. And nobody cared at all about the dialogue. Wow. So it actually gave me more permission to be, to have my sense of humor in it. Because my sense of humor isn't always like,
或者诸如此类的东西。当我加入漫威时，他们给我的唯一意见全都是关于动作场面周围的故事板。而没有人对对白有任何意见。哇。所以这实际上给了我更多的许可去发挥，让我的幽默感融入其中。因为我的幽默感并不总是那种，
not every joke lands. And like, if you're expecting it, you got to punch the joke and like, it's not funny enough. But if it's not expected to be funny, and it's just kind of dry. It can be a grin. Then it's a grin or just dialogue. Like they're not judging, you're not being.
不是每个笑话都能响。而且如果你有所期待，你必须去抖这个包袱，而且，这还不够搞笑。但如果它不被期望去搞笑，而只是有点冷幽默。它可以是一个会心一笑。那这就是一个会心一笑或者只是对话。就像他们没有在评判，你没有在被审视。
Right. When you cast Downey in there to bring in his sauce on top of that, it's a fringe benefit. It's an added asset that it didn't need to have, right? I mean, if you just had the action, apropos of the only thing they were noting. The personality of Marvel comics, like I grew up with, there was always a tongue-in-cheek kind of.
对。当你把唐尼选进电影里，在这一切之上加入他的个人魅力时，这是一个额外的福利。这是一个本不需要具备的附加资产，对吧？我的意思是，如果你只有动作戏，恰好切合了他们唯一在提意见的地方。漫威漫画的人格魅力，就像我成长时接触到的那样，总是有一种半开玩笑的风格。
Okay, gotcha. It wasn't as like earnest as DC. But they gave you, by virtue of that, they were kind of like, yeah, hit all these moments. This action stuff that's really important. And the rest of it, you can have that. Yeah, she'll go for it. And hit this budget.
好吧，明白了。它不像DC那样一本正经。但正因为如此，他们基本上就像是，是的，把所有这些时刻都拍出来。动作戏真的很重要。至于剩下的部分，你可以自己发挥。是的，她会支持的。并且达到这个预算。
And hit this budget. And then the stuff in between, yeah, go for it. If you want to have them be kind of interesting and be quirky and have a joke here, they're like, yeah, go for it, we're fine with that. And that's, I mean, that's very freeing, I imagine. But about Elf though, I read a long time ago, or I don't know when, that you set out,
并且达到这个预算。然后中间的部分，是的，去发挥吧。如果你想让他们的角色变得有趣、古怪并在某个地方开个玩笑，他们会说，是的，去吧，我们觉得可以。我的意思是，我能想象这非常具有解放性。不过关于《精灵总动员》，我很久以前读到过，或者我不知道是什么时候，你出发时，
I don't know if this is true, you tell me, to make a movie that was a classic Christmas film to be viewed for the rest of time. Like that was the goal of that movie. And a lot of people go into making stuff like that, but that doesn't happen. And it happened with you, with that goal in mind. I mean, that's amazing.
我不知道这是否属实，你告诉我，你是为了拍一部经典圣诞电影，能够在未来的岁月里一直被观看。就像那是那部电影的目标。很多人去拍这样的东西，但并没有发生。而你做到了，带着这个目标。我的意思是，这太惊人了。
That was the hope, you know what I mean? Because you think about like, what's the success of, if you're gonna be, because we're all friends with Peter Billingsley also. And he cameoed in that. And his work is either director or producer with us on different projects over the years. Somebody else who grew up,
那是当时的希望，你知道我的意思吗？因为你会想，成功的标准是什么，如果你要成为，因为我们和彼得·比灵斯利也是朋友。他在里面客串了。多年来，他的作品作为导演或制片人与我们在不同的项目上合作过。另一个人成长于，
won a good example of somebody who comes up through the business and learns the ropes and then continues to, you know, have an inspired career. And he, you know, it was interesting to know him because he was in Christmas story. And there, you know, the hope is that you could have a, make a movie that could sit alongside of a film like that, that's in rotation every year.
一个很好地通过这一行成长并了解门路，然后继续拥有富有灵感职业生涯的例子。而且他，你知道的，认识他很有趣，因为他演过《圣诞故事》。在那里，你知道的，希望你能拍出一部电影，能与这样一部每年都在循环播放的电影并驾齐驱。
I don't know if it still works this way. I think it does. Like TV would run a certain, there was a certain amount of films, like it's a wonderful life and Rudolph the Red Nose Reindeer and Charlie Brown, right? So to be in that pantheon of films that run in constant rotation around the holidays was always the hope.
我不知道现在是否还是这样。我想是的。就像电视台会播放某些，有一定数量的电影，比如《生活多美好》、《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》和《查理·布朗》，对吧？所以能够进入那些在节假日期间不断循环播放的电影殿堂，一直是我们的希望。
And we got to be there. And part of it was, remember it's also after 9-11. So, you know, I'm from New York and 9-11, you know, New York after 9-11, it's just everything like the music stopped. It was just like everybody thought in New York, they thought of that. And here we were filming a year later.
而我们做到了。部分原因是因为，记住这也是在9·11之后。所以，你知道的，我是纽约人，9·11，你知道9·11之后的纽约，一切就像音乐停止了。就像纽约的每个人都在想着这件事。而我们一年后在那里拍摄。
But there hasn't been, I mean, name the last hit, like Christmas movie that's consistent with Elf does. I can't think of it unless there is one. And I don't even know if there are movies like that anymore. Like everything is so on demand now. I know that like there's a lot of chatter online about Elf every year. And I know like even though we didn't have it
但并没有——我的意思是，说出最近的一部热门圣诞电影，能够像《精灵总动员》那样具有持久力的。我想不出来，除非有一部。我甚至不知道现在还有没有这样的电影。就像现在一切都是点播一样。我知道网上每年都有很多关于《精灵总动员》的讨论。我知道尽管当时我们没有制作周边商品，
merchandise made at the time, I see Christmas ornaments and blankets and costumes and ugly sweaters. So it's part of the culture. And now there's also people who grew up with these movies. So that's even stranger for me. Cause it's like, oh, we're, or like I'm introducing, it's our kids first time watching Elf.
我看到圣诞饰品、毯子、服装和丑毛巾。所以它是文化的一部分。现在也有伴随着这些电影长大的人。所以这对我来说更奇怪。因为就像，哦，我们在，或者就像我在介绍，这是我们孩子们第一次看《精灵总动员》。
And they'll like post a video of that. And that to me is the best like that. That's really cool. And if I had to pick one film I'm most proud of, like it might be that one because it, because it has such an intergenerational thing. It makes people feel a certain way around that time of year. And it feels like it's enduring, you know,
他们会发一段那样的视频。对我来说，那是最好的感觉。那真的很酷。如果我必须选一部我最引以为傲的电影，那可能是那部，因为它具有如此跨代际的特质。它让人们在一年中的那个时间感受到某种特定的情绪。而且它感觉经久不衰，你知道的，
and it felt old even when it came out cause it was stop motion and forced perspective. We didn't have a lot of CGI in it. So, and that, a lot of that was budget too. It's like we couldn't afford CGI. I saw the behind the scenes of it too, the making of it. And it was like what you did with the angles to make will, it's so, it's so easy and simple.
而且即使在它刚上映时也感觉很古老，因为它使用了定格动画和强迫透视。我们在其中没有使用太多CGI。所以，这很大程度上也是出于预算的考虑。就像我们承担不起CGI一样。我也看过幕后花絮，它的制作过程。就像你用角度让威尔显得那样，太轻松简单了。
It's an old trick. Yeah, like from Darby O'Gill and the little people. I mean, that's Lord of the Rings used it too. What about Faizon in that? How great was Faizon? I know, that's the, if I land on a scene from that, it's him and Will arguing with each other in the North Pole. We'll be right back.
这是一种老把戏。对啊，就像《达比·欧吉尔与小人国》里的那样。我是说，《指环王》也用过。那里面费宗表现怎么样？费宗演得有多好？我知道，如果我刚好看到那一幕，那就是他和威尔在北极争吵。我们马上回来。
Thank you to our newest sponsor Topgolf for supporting this podcast. Now it is golf, it's not golf, it's Topgolf. Now they got a bunch of stuff that makes them golf, right? They got the clubs, the balls, the T's, the turf, a ball picker, upper cart thing. They also have a whole bunch of stuff that is not golf. They've got loud music, giant targets in the giant fairway,
感谢我们最新的赞助商 Topgolf 对本播客的支持。现在它是高尔夫，也不是高尔夫，它是 Topgolf。他们有很多让它成为高尔夫的东西，对吧？他们有球杆、球、球座、草皮、捡球器、小车之类的东西。他们还有一大堆根本不是高尔夫的东西。他们有劲爆的音乐、巨型球道上的巨型靶子，
giant TVs, handcrafted food and beverage. Put all these things together under one roof. You got yourself a good time. You've got yourself, say it with me, Topgolf. So, consider this your formal invitation to grab the family, a few friends or some coworkers and come play around. Don't golf, that doesn't matter, listener. Everyone can play Topgolf even if no one can swing a club
巨型电视，手工餐饮。把所有这些东西放在一个屋檐下。你就收获了一段好时光。你收获了——跟我一起说——Topgolf。所以，这就当是你的正式邀请，带上家人、几个朋友或一些同事来玩上一局。不会打高尔夫？没关系，听众朋友。每个人都可以玩 Topgolf，即使没人会挥杆，
because do you like to eat? I bet the answer is yes. Do you like to have a good time? I'll bet the answer is hell to the yeah. And I'll bet you like to watch some TV and root on a friend, right? They got all that stuff at Topgolf. That's what I love about this place, Topgolf.
因为你喜欢吃东西吗？我敢说答案是肯定的。你喜欢玩得开心吗？我敢说答案是绝对的。我敢说你喜欢看电视并为朋友加油，对吧？Topgolf 里这些东西应有尽有。这就是我喜欢这个地方的原因，Topgolf。
What their whole sort of idea is that you can get into golf, enjoy golf without actually having to do the full commitment of going up there, playing 18 holes or even nine holes and, you know, putting on the collared shirt and the trousers and the whole, all the rules that kind of make golf kind of fun and interesting. I kind of like that stuff.
他们这种理念的全部意义在于，你可以接触高尔夫，享受高尔夫，而不必真正去做那种全套的承诺，比如大老远跑去打满 18 个洞甚至 9 个洞，你知道的，还要穿上领衬衫、西裤，以及一整套让高尔夫变得有趣又有吸引力的规则。我其实挺喜欢那些玩法的。
But if that's not your thing and you like more the kind of the free flowing kind of fun, let's go out and get a couple of drinks and just smack the ball around and see if I even know what the hell I'm doing with golf. This is your spot. It's awesome. Anyway, visit topgolf.com slash smartlist to book any bay
但如果那不是你的菜，你更喜欢那种比较自由随性的快乐，让我们出去喝上几杯，随便把球击出去，看看我特么到底知不知道自己在打什么高尔夫。这里就是你的绝佳去处。太棒了。总之，访问 topgolf.com 斜杠 smartlist 来预订任何一个击球区，
and come play around. Again, that is topgolf.com slash smartlist. Well, I'd be remiss if I didn't say that our next partner is Athletic Greens. First of all, let me just start by saying I take AG1 by Athletic Greens literally every day. I gave AG1 to try. I'm gonna say it was about maybe just under two years ago
然后来玩个痛快。再次重申，网址是 topgolf.com 斜杠 smartlist。好了，如果我不说我们的下一个合作伙伴是 Athletic Greens，那我可就失职了。首先，让我先声明一点，我literally每天都在服用 Athletic Greens 的 AG1。我尝试 AG1，
because I kind of wanted to, I felt like I was missing something. I've never been like a huge supplement guy or done doing any of that kind of stuff. But I thought AG1, Athletic Greens, I'd sort of heard about it. I started doing it, but I don't know. I maybe started taking it because of the show.
我得说大概是在不到两年前吧，因为我当时觉得，我感觉自己缺了点什么。我从来都不是那种超级热衷于营养补剂或者搞这些乱七八糟东西的人。但我想 AG1，Athletic Greens，我以前好像听说过。我开始喝了，不过我也说不清。我可能最初是因为这个节目才开始喝的。
There's a possibility that that's what happened. But whatever happened was I started doing it and then the boys and Rob and Bennett started doing it. And we all started noticing, first of all, I had better gut health. I felt more energized. And I knew that they'd said they could like, it would optimize my immune system,
不排除有这种可能。但不管怎么说，我开始喝了，然后这群兄弟、Rob 和 Bennett 也开始喝了。我们都开始注意到，首先，我的肠道健康变好了。我感觉更有活力了。而且我知道他们说过这可以，它能优化我的免疫系统，
which that sounds good. Sounds better than not getting an optimized immune system. But I hated taking vitamins and all that stuff. Anyway, so we started doing it. It is the best option for easy optimal nutrition out there. You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75, high quality vitamins, minerals, whole food source, superfoods and probiotics and adaptogens
听起来确实不错。总比免疫系统没被优化要好。但我讨厌吃维生素和所有这些东西。不管怎样，我们还是开始服用了。它是目前获取简便、最佳营养的最佳选择。你只需要喝一勺 AG1，就能吸收 75 种高品质的维生素、矿物质、全食物来源的超级食物、益生菌以及适应原，
to help you start your day right. And this blend of ingredients supports your gut health, your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, your recovery, focus, aging, all of that. For me, it's been such an unbelievably positive experience. I love talking about, first of all, I annoy a lot of people with AG1 because everybody in my house, I'm like, why don't you try it?
来帮助你开启美好的一天。这种成分组合支持你的肠道健康、神经系统、免疫系统、能量、恢复、注意力和抗衰老，方方面面。对我来说，这是一段好得难以置信的积极经历。我喜欢谈论它，首先，我用 AG1 烦死很多人了，因为我家里每个人我都劝：你们怎么不试试呢？
I want to get Alessandra on it. I'm always talking. Bateman gets annoyed by pretty much everything because he's so cranky all the time. And maybe Jason would be a little less cranky if he'd just listened to me and take it every single day. I bet you if you could look at the days he's cranky, those are the days that he missed taking AG1.
我想让亚历桑德拉（Alessandra）也开始喝。我一直在唠叨。贝特曼（Bateman）几乎对什么都烦，因为他总是那么暴躁。说不定杰森（Jason）要是肯听我的话，每天都喝一杯，就不会那么暴躁了。我敢说，如果你去看看他暴躁的日子，那肯定都是他忘了喝 AG1 的日子。
And right now it is time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just a scoop of AG1, one scoop in a cup of water every day and you don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out, all that stuff just to look out for your health. Now, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one year supply of immune supporting vitamin D
现在是时候重塑你的健康，用便捷的日常营养武装你的身体了。每天只要一勺 AG1，把一勺粉倒进一杯水里，你就不需要成百万种不同的药丸和补剂来照顾好你的健康了。现在，Athletic Greens 将在你的首次购买中免费提供一整年支持免疫系统的维生素 D，
and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartlist to give AG1 a try. That's athleticgreens.com slash smartlist. Check it out. And now, back to the show. So, you know, I mean, we touched on this already, but you're part of one of the biggest movie
以及五包免费旅行装。访问 athleticgreens.com 斜杠 smartlist 来尝试一下 AG1。网址是 athleticgreens.com 斜杠 smartlist。去看看吧。好了，现在，回到节目中。所以，你知道的，我是说，我们之前已经聊过这个了，但你现在是最大的电影公司之一——漫威的成员了。然后你又去了迪士尼和《星球大战》系列，你到底是怎么去那边的？简直太不可思议了。
companies now Marvel. And then you go over to Disney and the Star Wars franchise and how in the world did you get over there? Like, it's unbelievable. Well, I was working on finishing The Lion King and those movies take many, many years to, not many, many, but it takes a few years to finish because you're overseeing animation, visual effects,
嗯，我当时正在忙着完成《狮子王》，那些电影需要很多很多年去……也不是很多很多，但需要好几年才能完成，因为你要监督动画、视觉效果、后期制作，所有这些东西。所以你必须全神贯注。你不能抽身去做别的事情，因为你必须非常及时地审批镜头，你知道的，它们一出来就要批，这样才能让机器继续运转。而且，这依然不是一份全职工作，因为你不需要每天去片场。所以每天有几个小时你必须保持在线，
finally, all that stuff. So you have to be attentive. You can't go off and do something else because you have to approve shots very, you know, as soon as they come out, just to keep the machine going. And, but it's still not a full-time job because you're not going to set every day. So for a couple of hours each day, you have to be available,
但你不能离开去做别的事情，因为它需要大量细致的、你知道的专注力来把每个镜头做好，但这并不占用你全部的时间。所以我就开始琢磨，他们当时讨论过迪士尼+（Disney Plus）的推出，并且我们将会有电视剧，可能还有漫威的内容。
but you can't go off and do something else because it just takes a lot of meticulous, you know, concentration to get every shot right, but it doesn't require all your time. And so I started thinking about, they had talked about Disney Plus launching and that we're going to have TV shows and maybe Marvel stuff.
而且我几年前就和凯茜·肯尼迪（Kathy Kennedy）聊过，当时他们刚开始，当《星球大战》转移到迪士尼、从卢卡斯影业售出时，我们就聊过也许可以参与一部电影的想法。我是《星球大战》的粉丝。所以我向她推销了这个想法，我直接走进去，提出了《曼达洛人》的创意，
And I had talked to Kathy Kennedy years before when they were, when they first, when Star Wars moved over to Disney, was sold from Lucasfilm about the notion of maybe working on a movie. I was a fan of Star Wars. And so I pitched her, I just went in there and pitched the idea for the Mandalorian
一个非常简单的故事，讲的是一个，你知道的，我设想的第一场戏是赏金猎人走进一家酒吧。太棒了。事情就是这样。所以她很感兴趣。他们当时非常忙，因为他们正在准备上映《天行者传奇》的最后一部电影。
of a very simple story about a, you know, I was the first scene bounty hunter walks into a bar. So great. This happens. And so she was into it. They were very busy because they had the last movie of the Skywalker saga that they were getting ready to release.
所以那是他们的主要工作重心。于是我们开始谈论合作协议。接下来我直接就开始写了。所以当他们正式雇佣我的时候，我已经写好了四集剧本。哇。然后我把那些拿给他们，我说：“这就是我想做的。”
So that was their main focus. So we started talking about doing a deal. Next thing I just started writing. So by the time they actually hired me, I had written four episodes of it. Wow. And so I brought that in. I was like, this is what I want to do.
而且我不能离开镇子，因为我正在忙着完成《狮子王》，这对迪士尼来说是一件大事，而且属于同一家母公司，对吧？我们就是这样建立的，我们就是这样获得支持来搭建“立体空间”（The Volume）并开发你刚才提到的那套拍摄系统的。我正想说，
And I can't leave town because I'm working on finishing Lion King, which is a big deal for Disney, which is the same parent company, right? And that's how we built, that's how we got the support to build the volume and develop that filming system you were talking about. I was going to say,
所以“虚拟制片舞台”（StageCraft）是在《曼达洛人》之前还是之后？不，是在之后，因为一旦我们开始制作《曼达洛人》，我说：“听着，这里有一些技术，”有一些我所了解的技术。而且没有人——那是一种每个人都知道你可以做到，但没有人付诸实践的技术。
so did the stage craft come before Mandalorian or the Mandalorian? No, after, because once we started to do Mandalorian, I said, look, here's some tech, there was some technology I was aware of. And nobody, it was the type of thing where everybody knew you could do it, but nobody did it.
所以我走进去说：“好吧，目标是这样的。”我们聚集了一群人，ILM、Unreal、Lux screens、Magnopus，有很多技术合作伙伴与我的公司 Golem Creations 走到了一起。我们聚在一起，开始研究如何实现这一点。当时我们并不知道你实际上可以
And so I came in and said, okay, here's the goal. And we assembled a group of people, ILM, Unreal, Lux screens, Magnopus, there were a bunch of tech partners that came together along with my company, Golem Creations. And we all got together and started to work out how you would do this. And we didn't know that you could actually
在摄影机前完成这么多的镜头。当时这只是一个实验。但我们开始做一些小测试，甚至在我制作《狮子王》的时候就开始了，你可以移动摄影机，面前有一个电视屏幕，然后你会看到背景在移动。这看起来非常有前景。所以其中的一部分原因是为了让我能够完成
accomplish so many shots in camera. It was an experiment at the time. But we started doing little tests, even when I was working on Lion King, where you'd move the camera, you'd have a TV screen and you'd see the backgrounds move. And it seemed very promising. So part of that was to allow me to finish
这部对他们来说优先级极高的大制作电影《狮子王》，而不用离开小镇，同时还能开始筹备和制作这个项目。这就是为什么会有其他导演加入进来。我几乎写完了所有、差不多所有的剧本。这也是我学到的对制作真正有帮助的另一件事，那就是拥有一个统一的声音，非常深入地参与到剧作过程中，而不是……你可以让其他人来导演，
this big high priority film Lion King for them without leaving town and start to prep and work on this. And that's why there were other directors that came in. I wrote pretty much all, almost all the scripts. That's something else I learned really as helpful to is to have a unified voice to be very involved with the writing process and not have it. And you can have other people direct it,
但在剧本中保持一个恒定的、一致的声音，对于营造这种感觉来说真的是、真的是太有帮助了。对，把斯科蒂叫过来。斯科蒂，你想来点吗？你想知道什么？放轻松，肖恩。对。
but to have a constant, a consistent voice in the writing is really, is really helpful to make it feel like that. Yeah, bring Scotty over. Scotty, you want any? What do you want to know? Keep it loose, Sean. Yeah.
小尤达已经 50 岁了。我喜欢他尖叫的样子。嘿！怎么回事？我写了一个问题。你写了。让我们听听这个问题。听听看。
Baby Yoda is 50 years old. I love the way he screams. Hey! What's going on? I wrote down a question. You did. Let's hear the question. Let's hear it.
好吧，你来问。斯科蒂，过来用这个麦克风。一个嘉宾提问。接电话。好吧，这是我的问题。我知道它有点长。凑近麦克风。你可能已经被问过一千次了。
Well, you ask it. Scotty, get on the mic here. A guest question. Call her. Okay, so here's my question. I know it's long. Eat the mic. You've probably been asked this a thousand times.
这就对了。我很抱歉。显然，《曼达洛人》是一部非常了不起的剧。我们爱死它了。我们太喜欢它了。你哭了吗，斯科蒂？而且这是一部很棒的剧，填补了我们最喜爱的某些角色的空白，
There we go. I apologize. Obviously, The Mandalorian is such a phenomenal show. We love it. We love it so much. Are you crying, Scotty? And it's a great show for filling in the gaps for some of our favorite characters
比如卢克，他已经客串过好几次了。我不知道，我确信我们的一些粉丝会好奇，我们有没有可能在接下来的剧集中看到我们其他最喜欢的角色登场，那些我们知道在这个时间点上还活著的角色？这感觉就像我们在参加动漫展（Comic-Con）。我懂。
from the original Star Wars movies, like Luke and who's made a few appearances. And I don't know, I'm sure some of us fans were wondering, could we possibly see any of our other favorite characters show up maybe in upcoming episodes who we know to be alive at this point in time? It's like we're at Comic-Con. I know.
嗨，我是来自洛杉矶的斯科特。你知道，首先，我真的不能回答那个问题。但我会说，我们努力在《曼达洛人》中做的事情的一部分是……我还是要回答。哦，他听得见。他听得见。或者他听得见。是那种情况吗？
Hi, I'm Scott from Los Angeles. You know, first of all, I can't really answer that one. But I would say that part of what we try to do with The Mandalorian is, I'll still answer. Oh, he can hear. He can hear. Or he can. Is it one of those things?
那我挂断电话，在节目外听答案，就像在国家公共广播电台（NPR）一样。所以我觉得对我们来说重要的是，《星球大战》有如此多不同的领域，我们可以把所有这些都融入到一个节目中，把续集、前传、原创三部曲、动画甚至衍生宇宙的东西都融合进来。是的，这有点，太神奇了。
So I'll hang up and take the answer off air, like on NPR. So I think the important thing is for us is that there's so many different areas of Star Wars and that we could bring all of it together into one show and pull in things from the sequels, from the prequels, from the original trilogy, from the animated, and even the extended universe. Yeah, it's kind of, it's amazing.
感觉《星球大战》正在分裂成许多不同的领域。我们想做的事情之一就是把它全部拉拢回来，因为，你知道的，《星球大战》是一个大帐篷，对吧？而且，无论是看着《克隆人战争》长大的孩子们，还是经历过前传的千禧一代，每个人，每个人都被邀请参加这个派对。
It felt like Star Wars was splitting into a lot of different areas. And part of what we want to do is pull it all together because, you know, Star Wars is a big tent, you know? And there's, and whether it's kids who are growing up, watching Clone Wars or millennials who had the prequels, like everybody's, everybody's invited to the party.
所以有时这是顺理成章的。以卢克·天行者为例，当我们琢磨着如果他必须把格罗古带给一个绝地武士，而那个绝地武士会是谁时，除了卢克之外，换作任何人都不合逻辑。所以我们总是希望故事指引我们走到那里。马克·哈米尔（Mark Hamill）那个刚出现的 CGI 效果怎么样？
And so sometimes it makes sense. In the case of Luke Skywalker, as we were figuring out, if he had to bring him to a Jedi and who that Jedi would be, it made, it wouldn't have made logical sense for it to be anybody but Luke. So we always want the story to point us there. How about that CGI on Mark Hamill just come?
我的意思是，那太不可思议了。太疯狂了。同样疯狂的是，如果你看看我们第一次做的时候和接下来第二次做的时候之间的区别，你就会发现所有那些基于 AI 的技术……就像马克·哈米尔又年轻了 20 岁一样。我的意思是，虽然不是。
I mean, that was unbelievable. That was crazy. What's also crazy is if you look at the difference between the first time we did it and the next time we did it, you'll see how much all of that AI based It's like Mark Hamill was 20 years old again. I mean, it's not.
天呐，你们这群混蛋得去读本书。我的天呐。天呐。好了。你知道吗？你知道我们在聊什么吗？《豚鼠特工队》（G-Force），那是我们一起合作的电影。你想起来了。
God, you fucking people need to read a book. Jesus Christ. Christ. All right. You know what? You know what we got to talk about? GeForce, that's the movie we did together. You thought about it.
我们俩都在里面。我们俩都在里面。那是我们唯一一次合作。你、我、加利费安纳基斯（Galifianakis）、比尔·奈伊（Bill Nighy）。你知道加利费安纳基斯事后跟我说什么吗？我，他说：“那是，我向自己保证，拍完那部电影后，我再也不会在嗨了的状态下去读剧本了。”
We are both in it. We are both in it. That's the only time we work together. You, me, Galfinakis, Bill Nyee. You know what Galfinakis told me after that? I, he said, that's the, that's, I promise myself after that film that I would never read a script high before I,
他是这么对我的。来看看那个实验。太棒了。但老实说，让我们，让我们，让我们……你知不知道《豚鼠特工队》保持着什么记录？你为什么要把话题岔开？好吧，我想聊聊《史前星球》（Prehistoric Planet）。顺便说一句，我所有的孩子，我所有的孩子都经历过大约六个月的疯狂期，在他们四岁左右的时候，超级喜欢它。我每一个孩子都这样。是一群沙鼠，对吧？不对。
is what he said to me. See you into that experiment. That's amazing. But let's honestly, let's, let's, let's Did you ever know what GeForce has held it? Why are you moving off of this? Well, I want to get to prehistoric planning. By the way, all my kids, all my kids have gone through 20,
是豚鼠。是豚鼠。我刚才就是这么说的。
I've gone through like six months where they've loved it when they're like four. Every single one of my kids. It's a bunch of gerbils, right? No. It's guinea pigs. It's guinea pigs. That's what I said.
我当时演的是其中一只豚鼠。我是搞笑担当。我是那只放屁的豚鼠。我确信你的朋友，你的孩子们会喜欢我。超喜欢。我是最受欢迎的角色之一，对吧？他们超喜欢。我是说，他们在不同的阶段都超级喜欢。
I was one of the guinea pigs. I was the comic relief. I was the farting guinea pig. I'm sure your friend, your kids liked me. That loved. I was one of the favorites, right? They loved that. I mean, they all loved it at various stages.
胡利（Hurly），我演的是胡利。不管怎样，好吧，我们继续聊《史前星球》。话说，这个项目是怎么来的？给威斯康星州的特雷西（Tracy）解释一下这到底是个什么东西？特雷西，有个叫 Apple TV Plus 的好东西。如果你拥有它，就会看到一个纪录片系列，看起来非常像、听起来也非常像《地球脉动》（Planet Earth），
Hurly, I play hurly. Anyway, okay, let's go on to prehistoric planning. Now, how did that come about and explain to Tracy in Wisconsin what the hell it is? Tracy, there's a little something called Apple TV Plus. And if you get it, there's a documentary series that looks an awful lot and sounds an awful lot like Planet Earth
由大卫·爱登堡（David Attenborough）担任旁白。由 BBC 和 Apple TV 制作，我也参与其中，我们制作了一部纪录片，就好像你能够把一台摄影机带回到史前的白垩纪时期一样。是的，非常酷。我参与其中的原因在于，这是一个他们一直在讨论要合作的项目，
with David Attenborough narrating. Done by the BBC and Apple TV that I'm involved with and we create a documentary as though you were able to bring a camera back into the prehistoric, Cretaceous period. Yeah, it's pretty cool. And the reason I'm working on it is, it was a project that they were talking about doing,
但因为我们在制作《狮子王》的过程中开发了能够创造出更具电影感和真实照片级 CGI 的技术——如果你还记得的话，那里面没有实际的摄影画面。全部都是 CGI，但我们构建了一个我们在其中进行拍摄的 VR 环境。
partnering up on, but because we had developed technology to create CGI that felt more cinematic and photoreal through all of our innovations on the Lion King, which if you recall, there was no actual photography in that. That was all CGI, but we built a VR environment that we filmed in.
所以我们实际上让整个剧组都在 VR 中围绕着这些动画角色拍摄片段。这也是为什么它看起来，希望看起来像一部真人电影的部分原因。试着稍微解释一下，好让特雷西能明白这意味着什么。因为我觉得在 VR 中构建你正在拍摄的环境，对大家来说未必是一个容易理解的概念。
So we actually had the whole crew in VR filming segments around these animated characters. And that's part of why it looks like a, hopefully like a live action movie. Try to explain that a little bit, just so Tracy can understand what that means. Cause I think building the environment that you're filming in VR is not an easy concept necessarily.
不，但那是获得……就像我妈妈在家一样。我妈妈在家。她 76 岁了。不对，抱歉，天哪，她快 80 岁了。好吧，你可得把年龄搞对。她高兴得很。对，我知道她很高兴。
No, but it was the way to get- Like my mom's at home. My mom's at home. She's 76. No, sorry, God, she's almost 80. Well, make sure you get it right. She's thrilled. Yeah, I know she is.
亚历克斯，她不在乎。她不会被这种话冒犯的。所以她在家。你会怎么向我 80 岁的妈妈解释这意味着什么？好让她不觉得是 85 岁左右什么的，你知道吗？卡尔加里正在发掘。那是哪个省份？
Alex, she doesn't mind. She's not offended by stuff like that. So she's at home. How would you explain it to my mom who's 80, what that means? So she's not 85 or something, you know? Calgary is digging. What province is it?
多伦多。卡尔加里。我不知道。我不知道。19 岁。她是个阿尔戈英雄队（Argos）的球迷。她是个狂热的阿尔戈英雄队球迷。但向某个人解释一下。
Toronto. Calgary. I don't know. I don't know. 19. She's an Argo fan. She's a big Argo fan. But explain it to somebody.
多伦多。卡尔加里。我不知道。我不知道。19。她是个阿尔戈队球迷。她是个忠实的阿尔戈队球迷。但向别人解释一下。
So virtual reality is something where you wear goggles and wherever you turn your head and move, you perceive through hearing and sight as though you're immersed in that reality. So it's like a video game. She understands that. So we create the environment with artists. As you would for CGI, we create the environment
所以虚拟现实就是你戴上护目镜，无论你把头转到哪里、怎么移动，你的听觉和视觉感知都像身临其境一样。所以它就像一个电子游戏。她懂这个。所以我们和艺术家一起创建环境。就像制作CGI特效一样，我们创建环境
and the characters. And so if you're wearing your goggles, you could walk around and look at and interact with the environment and the characters. That allows us like a multiplayer game to bring the crew into that virtual environment. And so you could have a cinematographer and a gaffer in there setting lights up virtually.
和角色。如果你戴着护目镜，你就可以四处走动、观察并与环境和角色互动。这让我们能够像玩多人游戏一样，把剧组人员带入那个虚拟环境中。所以你可以让摄影师和灯光师在里面虚拟地设置灯光。
You could have a camera operator set up a camera. And we would, you know, if you came to our stages down there in Silicon Beach, down there off Jefferson, Culver City, that area, we had set up their camera systems without cameras. Dolly tracks without cameras on them. We had sensors. So all your crew is wearing goggles?
你可以让摄像师架设摄像机。而且我们会——你知道的，如果你去我们在硅谷海滩那里的片场，杰斐逊路那边，卡尔弗城那个地区，我们在那里搭建了没有摄像机的摄像机系统。没有安放摄像机的摇臂轨道。我们有传感器。所以你们所有的剧组人员都戴着护目镜？
So some of them would be wearing goggles to scout, but you could also watch a screen because a Dolly grip isn't necessarily having to see a fully dimensionalized version of the performer. They just have to look at their marks. So they would tape marks off on a track and move the chassis. And that gave the whole thing a feel
所以其中一些人会戴着护目镜去勘景，但你也可以看屏幕，因为摇臂推轨操作员不一定非要看到表演者的全维度版本。他们只需要看好自己的标记。所以他们会在轨道上用胶带贴出标记并移动底盘。这就让整个过程有一种感觉
as though it was being filmed in live action. Wow. So by building these tools, it gave it that live action feel in addition to really good CGI that MPC was able to do. The house that we work with. So we had all these tools that we built around how do you make Lion King look live action?
就像是在拍摄真人动作片一样。哇。所以通过构建这些工具，除了MPC能够制作的非常棒的CGI之外，它还赋予了真人动作片的感觉。也就是我们合作的那家公司。所以我们围绕着“如何让《狮子王》看起来像真人实景”构建了所有这些工具？
And we use those tools and applied them to the task of how do you create a show that looks like a documentary filmed in real life of dinosaurs? And so if you look at Prius Dark Planet, if you have Apple TV Plus, you could take a look at it. We've got a season up, we're getting ready to launch another that we're just finishing up now.
然后我们使用这些工具，并将它们应用到“如何制作一部看起来像是恐龙现实生活纪录片”的任务中。所以如果你看了《史前星球》，如果你有Apple TV Plus，你可以去看一下。我们已经上线了一季，我们正准备推出另一季，现在刚刚完成后期制作。
And you could, or you could look on trailers if you don't have that and take a look at it. And then we had David Attenborough and just his voice over. Yeah, pretty cool. And it's all based in real science, which again, I geek out on because I get to learn so much about the behavior. Archeology has made so many breakthroughs
如果你没有那个平台，你也可以看看预告片了解一下。然后我们邀请了戴维·阿滕伯格只负责画外音。对，非常酷。而且这一切都建立在真正的科学基础之上，这再次让我这个极客兴奋不已，因为我能了解到那么多关于它们行为的知识。考古学取得了如此多的突破
in the last few years where you start to learn about how they reared their young, where they lived, that they had feathers, they were colorful, they had, it was a whole different sense of what dinosaurs were than when I grew up. I forgot about that time, what were we doing? Was it couples retreat and I went in your trailer
在过去几年里，你开始了解到它们是如何抚养幼崽的、它们住在哪里、它们有羽毛、它们色彩斑斓、它们拥有——这与我成长时对恐龙的认知完全是两码事。我忘了那段时间了，我们在干嘛？那是《情侣退修会》吗，我去了你的拖车
and you walked in my trailer, I remember this. Yeah, you were watching this series of videotapes at the time, I think the DVDs. That's a good memory, it was DVDs, it was a box set of, it was called Big History. Big History, David Christian would teach a course in it. It was one of those, it was before, remember it was before like podcasts or before digital.
然后你走进了我的拖车，我记得这个。对，你当时在看这一系列录像带，我想是DVD。记忆力真好，是DVD，是一个盒装套装，叫做《大历史》。《大历史》，大卫·克里斯蒂安会讲授一门相关的课程。那是那种——在播客或数字时代之前，你还记得吗。
So we are watching on the viewer in the trailer. And Big History, I'm sure it's still available, was a fascinating course because it starts off with the Big Bang, talking about the world through the lens of physics, and then through the formation of the stars and planets, and then it talks about chemistry, and then it talks about geology as the planets formed,
所以我们在拖车里的显示器上观看。而《大历史》，我确信它现在依然可以看，是一门引人入胜的课程，因为它从大爆炸开始，通过物理学的镜头来讲述世界，然后通过恒星和行星的形成，接着讲化学，然后随着行星的形成讲地质学，
and then it eventually talks about anthropology, and comes all the way through history today with complex systems and the patterns. Yeah, this sounds amazing. It was just, I mean, we just go in there and we just watch the TV for like hours. Jason, you said that behind, when you were like 16, here we go.
然后它最终讲到人类学，一直通过复杂系统和模式讲到今天的历史。对，这听起来太棒了。这简直——我是说，我们就是去那里看好几个小时的电视。杰森，你说过在背后，当你16岁的时候，来吧。
On Ventura, behind the Ralphs, you had a lot of chemistry on the Big Bang, right? You had a lot of chemistry on the Big Bang, right? You were 16. And then I told you I had three callbacks for the show, the Big Bang. No, but you've always been interested in, I love that about you.
在文图拉，拉尔夫超市后面，关于大爆炸你有很多化学知识，对吧？关于大爆炸你有很多化学知识，对吧？你当时16岁。然后我告诉你我有三个试播集的回电，《生活大爆炸》。不，但你一直对——我太喜欢你这一点了。
You're, there's so much about you that is beautifully silly, and without sort of pretense, and then there's another part of this super big brain in you, and you just, you're a real inspiration, Mr. And also, does everybody know that we work together one of my first jobs in town?
你有很多地方都美妙地透着傻气，而且没有什么做作，然后你的脑子里还有超级强大的一面，你真的——你是一个真正的灵感源泉，先生。还有，大家知道我们在这个镇上的第一份工作之一就是一起合作的吗？
That's right. We're on a pilot together. Wait, I think, did I get fired? I think I got fired from that show. I think, I might be confusing with another one, but I did get fired off the pilot. You were the big star. You were when they got you.
没错。我们在一个试播集里合作过。等等，我想，我是不是被解雇了？我想我被那个节目解雇了。我想，我可能是把它跟另一个搞混了，但我确实从那个试播集被解雇了。你是大明星。他们得到你时，你就是大明星。
That was the big win. We never went to air, by the way, but it was a big thing for me. I got a phone call that I was going to be replaced, and then 48 hours later I heard that they were actually not going to pick up the show. So I had to live with it. I had the honor of being fired before.
那是场大胜。顺便说一句，我们节目后来从未播出，但这对我来说是一件大事。我接到一个电话，说我要被替换了，然后48小时后我听说他们实际上不打算接手这个节目了。所以我不得不接受现实。我有过被解雇的荣誉。
Yeah, being fired, and then the whole show got fired. Maybe without Jason. No, let's not do it at all. Is that what happened? Wait, what was it? What was it? It was, we played comedy writers on a, like, proscenium, multi-cam sitcom pilot.
对，被解雇了，然后整个节目都被炒了。也许没有杰森。不，我们还是别演了。事情是这样的吗？等等，那是什么？那是什么？那是我们在一个镜框式、多机位情景喜剧试播集中饰演喜剧编剧。
Back in, it must have been like, 92, three? Did Robbie Benson direct that? No, am I thinking it was his mouse? It may have been. He directed a pilot that I did. Was it the same one? It might have been that one. Yeah, our brains are going.
回到过去，大概是92、93年吧？罗比·本森导演的那个吗？不对，我在想是不是他的老鼠？有可能是。他导演过我演的一个试播集。是同一个吗？有可能是那个。对，我们的脑子在转动。
Because he directed a friend, my friend's episode. I think he did direct, no, he directed, I don't know. Anyway, it was, I loved you then, I loved you now. We got to work together, man. That was the big time for me. Did you remember when you were working on Iron Man 2? Yes, Justin Thoreau. And what I was going to say, when you were reading this,
因为他导演了一个朋友，我朋友的一集。我想他确实导演过——不对，他导演过，我不知道。不管怎样，那是——我那时就爱你，现在也爱你。我们曾一起工作过，伙计。那对当时的我是个大场面。你还记得你拍摄《钢铁侠2》的时候吗？是的，贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。我想说的是，当你读到这个时，
when the pages- He has sleeves back then? When the pages were coming in, could you get the sense they were written by arms with no sleeves on them? I noticed that nobody had sleeves in the script. Yeah. Which I was curious about.
当那些页面——他当时有袖子吗？当那些剧本页送来时，你能感觉到它们是出自没有穿袖子的胳膊之手吗？我注意到剧本里没有人穿袖子。对。我对此很好奇。
That was the one thing. Like, I don't know if that's going to play. That's his hallmark. And the dog was going to start. That's his hallmark. He was great. He was a writer, he had worked with, he was a writer on Tropic Thunder.
那是唯一的一点。就像，我不知道这能不能行得通。那是他的招牌。而且那只狗要开始叫了。那是他的招牌。他太棒了。他是个编剧，他曾与——他是《热带惊雷》的编剧。
He and Ben still are wrote Tropic Thunder and then Downey won, yeah. Downey was a very big, you know, he was like, this is the guy that could, you know what I mean? Because it needs to be a voice too for Tony Stark. It wasn't just, you know, a lot of it came from him in the first one. Yeah.
他和本·斯蒂勒一起写了《热带惊雷》，然后唐尼赢了，是的。唐尼是一个非常大的，你知道的，他当时就像是，这就是那个能够——你知道我的意思吗？因为托尼·斯塔克也需要一个声音。这不仅仅是——你知道的，很大一部分在第一部里都来自于他。对。
So I think that he had a really good experience with Justin, he's a very smart guy. And like, again, another one who's an actor. Actor, right? But you talk to him about a lot of subjects. He knows a lot about a lot of things. And just a really, you know, has a really good ear for him. I saw, he sent me a picture the other night,
所以我认为他在贾斯汀身上有很好的经历，他是一个非常聪明的人。而且，同样地，另一个也是演员。演员，对吧？但你跟他谈论很多话题。他对很多事情都了解很多。而且确实——你知道的，对角色很有感觉。我看到，他前天晚上给我发了一张照片，
by the way, from New York. And great. And I love, you know, Thoreau is one of our best buddies, but he did send me a picture from New York out at night. He thought he was, he thought he was taunting me. And it was six degrees in New York, I knew because I'd seen on the weather and he was inside this establishment with no sleeves.
顺便说一句，从纽约发来的。非常棒。我喜欢——你知道，塞洛克斯是我们最好的哥们之一，但他确实从纽约的夜晚给我发了一张照片。他以为他在——他以为他在挑衅我。纽约当时是六度，我知道因为我在天气预报上看到了，而他正待在这个没有袖子的场所里面。
And I was like, hey man, it's fucking January. My guns like that, you couldn't get sleeves on me either. I would too, I would too. John, what does it take for you to get excited enough to treat us all to some of your great acting? Or are you just so satisfied with your creative? No, I love doing it. Well, with a guy like you.
我就像，嘿，老兄，这他妈可是的一月啊。我的肌肉像这样，你也休想给我套上袖子。我也会，我也会。约翰，你需要达到什么程度的兴奋，才会请我们大家欣赏你精湛的演技？还是说你对自己的创作已经如此满足？不，我喜欢这么做。好吧，对于像你这样的人。
You're funny as hell. But where does it sit in your temptations, you know? I mean, does it have as much of a pole as directing does? It depends who it's with and what it is. And it's not the same thrill as in the beginning when can I do this at all, right? And you just wanna make sure that you're in a situation where you're with people that you're having a good time.
你搞笑得要命。但它在你受到的诱惑里处于什么位置呢？我是说，它的吸引力有导演工作那么大吗？这取决于你跟谁合作以及合作的内容是什么。而且这已经不再是刚开始时那种“我到底能不能做到这一点”的刺激了，对吧？你只想确保你处于一种能与相处愉快的人在一起的环境中。
Because if you're not, I don't know that I could fake it as well as you need to. And also like, I love, look, when you get to work on your own stuff, you start, you have a lot of control over a lot of things. And so you use that part of your brain. And when you go on somebody else's set, if you bring that energy, it's terrible.
因为如果你不在，我不知道我是否能像你需要的那样伪装得那么好。而且还有像，我喜欢——听着，当你能参与你自己的作品时，你开始，你对很多事情都有很大的控制权。所以你会运用你大脑的那一部分。当你去别人的片场时，如果你带着那种能量，那就太糟糕了。
Like you have to be a great, and actually the people I've worked with who are the best actors are other filmmakers. Because they show up and they just want, where do you want me to stand? They're like the first ones on their marks. And like that's how I am when I go on somebody else's set. And I like to do the,
就像你必须成为一个伟大的人——实际上我合作过的最好的演员都是其他电影人。因为他们出现时只想要，你希望我站在哪里？他们就像是第一个站到自己标记上的演员。当我去了别人的片场时，我就是这样的。我喜欢做这件事，
I've been doing the Marvel stuff. And I think that's been really cool because I have to keep that connection. A lot of the characters that were around are gone now. And I'm like one of the ones who's around since the first Iron Man. And I'm still there for the kids who grew up. I'm like the Hagrid of Marvel.
我一直在做漫威的东西。我认为这真的很酷，因为我必须保持这种联系。周围的很多角色现在都消失了。而我是自第一部《钢铁侠》以来一直还在的人之一。对于那些伴随着它长大孩子们来说，我依然在那里。我就像是漫威的海格。
That's hysterical. You know, like a, hopefully like a friendly, goofy presence that offers some comfort. All right, last question. What, with all the smart stuff and great stuff that you're doing, what's the dumbest thing you find yourself doing on a daily or weekly basis?
太滑稽了。你知道的，就像一个——希望是一个友好、傻气的存在，能提供一些安慰。好了，最后一个问题。带着你正在做的所有聪明的事情和伟大的事情，你发现自己每天或每周都在做的最蠢的事情是什么？
Do you have any guilty pleasures that the audience would be surprised by? Well, there's a podcast I listen to religiously. Oh, right, your brain. That's my dirty pleasure, my guilty pleasure. That qualifies. No, I do love the podcast. And it's started off as something
你有什么会让观众感到惊讶的罪恶的快感吗？嗯，我有一个严格奉行的播客节目。哦，对了，你的大脑。那是我的不洁之乐，我的罪恶快感。那符合标准。不，我确实很喜欢这个播客。它一开始的时候
where I didn't know if I liked it just cause I knew all of you. And it was like, I was like, and I don't get out a lot. So I was like, oh, this is like hanging out. And I'm just not talking. Like I got to hang out with you guys. And I just had no pressure to be funny. No pressure to go, you know,
我还不知道我是不是真的喜欢它，只是因为我认识你们所有人。当时我想，而且我不常出门，所以我想，哦，这就像是一起闲逛。而我只是不说话。就像我有机会和你们一起闲逛。而且我没有任何要搞笑的压力。没有压力去说，你知道的，
I didn't have to belly the car or drive. And then now that it's such a success. And so many people when I mentioned I was going to do this show, they were like really like jealous. Like, oh my God, that's so fun. How do you get, what do they like? So it's really great to watch you all do something
我不用去兜风或开车。而现在它如此成功。当我提到我要做这个节目时，很多人都表现得非常嫉妒。就像，哦天哪，太有趣了。你怎么得到的，他们喜欢什么？所以看你们大家做一件
that something that you did for fun. Because you liked it and you were interested in it. Turned into one of the most successful projects for all of you. You know what I mean? That this is like such a win. The most successful for me, 40 years. This is like the biggest, loudest thing I've ever done.
你们纯粹为了好玩而做的事情，这感觉真的很好。因为你们喜欢它，并且对它感兴趣。结果它变成了对你们所有人来说最成功的项目之一。你知道我的意思吗？这真是一场大胜。对我来说最成功的，40年。这是我做过的最大、最轰动的事情。
And I love that this moment allows rewards, passion and authenticity that other people will seek it out and they sense it and they'll find it. And how relaxed everything is. And all the things that we've all worked on together apart. There was this pressure in the background of if you do this, you'll get to succeed or we'll let you do more of this.
我喜欢这个时刻能够奖励激情和真实感，其他人会去寻找它，他们能感觉到并会找到它。而且一切都是那么轻松。以及我们所有人一起或分开合作过的所有事情。背景中一直有一种压力：如果你这样做，你就会成功，或者我们会让你做更多这种事情。
Or we'll pick up this pilot if we like, if it tests well. And then this is the most unstructured. The concept is so is like one surprise guest and we're going to talk. And everybody's drawn to it. And it just shows you that all those rules and all those structures and the gatekeepers, all of that is a function of the dynamic
或者如果我们喜欢这个试播集，如果测试反应好，我们就会预定它。而这是最没有条理的。这个概念就是——就像一个惊喜嘉宾，我们要开始聊天。每个人都被它吸引了。它向你展示了所有那些规则、所有的结构和把关人，所有这些都是商业经济学动态的产物
around the economics of the business. And then here you all come through and do something where it's all of you hanging out. And as somebody who's hung out with all of you, it really feels exactly that way. And that people get a glimpse of it and that they enjoy it. And it actually turns into there's a business model to support it and a way to distribute.
而现在你们所有人都走过来，做了一件你们所有人聚在一起闲逛的事情。作为一个和你们所有人都闲逛过的人，它给人的感觉确实完全如此。人们能窥见它的全貌并乐在其中。它实际上变成了一个支持它的商业模式和分发渠道。
I think it's really encouraging. And to people out there who are going to, trying to figure out their way, it's a real lesson. Yeah, I was actually just saying that this morning, it was a real lesson to me that it shouldn't be a surprise that the thing that I think for all three of us that we have pushed least on or pressed least on in our careers has ended up being the most successful thing.
我认为这真的很鼓舞人心。对于那些正要——试图摸索自己道路的人来说，这真的是一个很好的教训。是的，我今天早上其实才刚说过，这对我是个极好的教训，我们三个人在职业生涯中投入最少或最不费力的事，最终竟成了最成功的事，这本不该让人感到意外。
And it is a great lesson. You just sort of just follow your instinct and just walk down the hill and... Well, we've never, as you know, and John, as you got to witness when we were first doing the intro, we never talk about what we're going to talk about. Here's the other thing we've all worked on.
这是一个很好的教训。你只需要顺从直觉，沿着山坡走下去……好吧，正如你所知，约翰，正如你第一次做开场白时亲眼目睹的那样，我们从不讨论我们要聊什么。还有一件事是我们都合作过的。
We've all worked on the Kyle Gas poker game back in the day about 15 years ago when we all played. But it's very much that same dynamic, right? It's just sitting down at a table and just having a laugh. And we never talk about what we're going to talk about ever, truly. Well, thanks for having me on it. Dude, thank you for fucking coming on. Your story is awesome.
我们大约在15年前都在凯尔·加斯的扑克局里玩过。但那是完全相同的动态，对吧？就是坐在桌子旁开怀大笑。而且我们从不讨论我们要聊什么，真的从来没有。好吧，谢谢你邀请我来。老兄，谢谢你他妈的能来。你的故事太棒了。
It's really cool. And I might add, when I see you and we hang out, however few and far between that is, I'm always so thrilled to see you and so enamored with you and everything that you do. I just, it's just, I'm so giddy because I'm just like, you know, from the first time we met 20 decades or two decades ago,
真的很酷。而且我还要补充一点，每当我看到你并我们一起闲逛时——尽管次数寥寥无几，但我总是非常高兴见到你，为你的魅力以及你所做的一切深深着迷。我只是——我太飘飘然了，因为我只是觉得，你知道的，从我们二十年前或两个十年初次相遇以来，
I mean, you know, it's really cool. Thank you. Also, John, I will implore you, from a guy who started doing swingers again, which is so great. And then you went and you've gone to such lofty heights and all the MCU and then the Star Wars and all that stuff. And then in between that, you do the chef.
我是说，你知道的，这真的很酷。谢谢。还有，约翰，我恳求你，作为一个重新开始拍《求爱俗辣》的人——这太棒了。然后你去了更高的高度，拍了所有的MCU，然后是《星球大局》以及所有这些东西。在这期间，你拍了《落魄大厨》。
I implore you to keep going back and please and give us another like indie like story, like a small story, please. Cause you're really good at that. You're really, really good at that. Thank you, man. Thank you all. And, you know, keep doing what you're doing.
我恳求你继续回去，求求你再给我们拍一个像独立电影一样的小故事，求求你。因为你真的很擅长那个。你真的、真的很擅长那个。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢大家。而且，你知道的，继续做你们正在做的事。
It's really wonderful. And it's wonderful also to feel like I could just jump on something like this and to feel like I've been hanging out with you all the way through, even though it's been a one-way street and especially through the lockdown, you know what I mean? Through the pandemic, it was really nice to have your voices and your presence and it just, everybody was so isolated.
这真的很棒。而且觉得我可以随时加入这样一档节目，并且感觉从头到尾都和你们在一起闲逛，尽管这曾经是一条单行道，尤其是在封城期间，你知道我的意思吗？在疫情期间，有你们的声音和陪伴真的很棒，每个人都那么孤立无援。
And I felt like it was really comforting, reassuring. And it's just, it's just enjoyable. And I'm glad that it's, your guys are still going and that everybody recognizes. And we can't wait for the next Avatar. That's you too, right? Yeah, that's me. Sean, please check your text.
我觉得这真的很安慰、很安心。而且这——这真的很愉快。我很高兴你们还在继续，每个人也都认可这一点。我们已经迫不及待地想看下一部《阿凡达》了。那也是你，对吧？对，那是我。肖恩，请查看你的信息。
John, well, thanks for being a part of it, buddy. Thanks, John. Really appreciate it. And hopefully we'll see you soon in person. All right. Bye, John. Bye, John. Bye, pal.
约翰，好吧，谢谢你能参与进来，老兄。谢谢你，约翰。非常感谢。希望我们很快能在现实中见面。好的。再见，约翰。再见，约翰。再见，老兄。
Thank you. Bye. Oh, he's gonna do it. He's gonna do it. He's gonna slam it. Shut the slam. No, slam it. I have a little switch on my thing.
谢谢。再见。哦，他要这么做。他要这么做。他要把它关上。闭上，关上。不，关上。我的设备上有一个小开关。
I had installed just for smartless. That goes over my camera, see? Nice. There it is. Perfect. Boy, I sure liked that fellow. Yeah, that was great. I mean, it was so good to check in from him.
我专门为了《聪明糊涂心》安装的。它可以盖住我的摄像头，看？太棒了。就是这样。完美。天哪，我真的很喜欢这家伙。对，那太棒了。我是说，能和他连线叙旧感觉太好了。
You forget about how many things he's done in sort of different shapes and sizes, right? Well, and I mentioned the thing, I mentioned it earlier, comparing him to like George Lucas in the sense that like he not only tells great stories and makes things that we all want to see, but like the tech part of it too,
你会忘记他在各种不同类型和规模的项目中做过多少事情，对吧？对，我刚才提到了，我之前说过，把他比作乔治·卢卡斯，不仅因为他能讲出极好的故事并做出我们都想看的东西，还因为科技方面的事情，
is like there's not a lot of people who do that. And he doesn't make a big thing about letting people know how many important things he's touched, how many things that we love that he's done that we might not realize he's been a part of. I just think that's really, I think that's really cool. Yeah. I mean, think about it.
很少有人能做到这一点。而且他不会大肆宣扬自己接触过多少重要的东西，有多少我们喜爱的事物是他参与制作的而我们可能并未察觉。我真的觉得这太酷了。真的。我是说，想想看。
He wrote swingers and starred in swingers with fans. And then he directed Elf, one of the all-time, an absolute Christmas classic. I mean, in their top two. Yeah, for sure. Of Christmas. It's a wonderful life and Elf. Yeah, yeah.
他写了《摇摆者》的剧本并和凡斯一起主演了《摇摆者》。接着他导演了《圣诞精灵》，那是有史以来的绝对经典，一部绝对的圣诞经典。我是说，排在他们心目前两名。对，毫无疑问。关于圣诞节的。《生活多美好》和《圣诞精灵》。对，对。
And the swingers, by the way, but before you go past that, like that kind of started a bit of a comedic style and tone and what was called. Well, it set the tone for all the Marvel movies. No, no, no, swingers just sort of set the tone for a lot of some of the comedies that populated, what was it, the 90s?
而且《摇摆者》，顺便说一句，在你跳过这个之前，它开创了一种喜剧风格和基调，以及所谓的……嗯，它为所有的漫威电影定下了基调。不，不，不，《摇摆者》只是为那些充斥于……是什么来着，90年代的很多喜剧定下了基调？
Yeah. Yeah. And with him and Vince starting to work through all this and Stiller and Owen Wilson and Jack Black and just sort of that wheel that was sort of birth, I think, right in there. Oh, the comedy wheel. Remember the comedy wheel?
对。对。还有他和凡斯开始一起琢磨所有这些，以及斯蒂勒、欧文·威尔逊、杰克·布莱克，还有那种刚好在那里诞生的圈子，我想，对吧？哦，喜剧圈。还记得喜剧圈吗？
And then, yeah, and as you were saying, then Elf and what that did for that films of that season and then, of course, yeah, what he did to set the tone for Marvel and all the other derivative films in that genre is pretty impressive. So we didn't talk about the film. Here we go. I love the way he's teeing himself.
然后，对，就像你刚才说的，接下来是《圣诞精灵》以及它对那个季节的电影所产生的影响，然后，当然，对，他为漫威以及该类型的其他衍生电影定下基调的做法相当令人印象深刻。所以我们刚才没聊那部电影。我们来啦。我喜欢他自己铺垫的方式。
We didn't talk. It's unbelievable. It's unbelievable. Hey guys, have you ever thought about it? You know, it's so embarrassing. And by the way, with this kind of buildup, it better be fun. It's really good.
我们没聊。太难以置信了。太难以置信了。嘿，伙计们，你们曾想过吗？你知道，这太尴尬了。顺便说一句，有这样的铺垫，最好真的很有趣。真的很不错。
We didn't talk about the film that he actually acted in with Jason, which was and Melissa McCarthy, which was by Denny Teasy. No, no, no, no, no, rejected at the gate. You see how timid he is about it. What the fuck could he even say it above a whisper? He was so ashamed of that. Fuck.
我们没聊他真正和杰森以及梅丽莎·麦卡西一起演的那部电影，也就是《身份贼鸥》。不，不，不，不，不，在门口就被否决了。你看他对此有多胆小。他妈的怎么能用气音之上的声音说出来？他对此太羞耻了。他妈的。
Is Postmates at the door? Do you have to run? Is that why you're trying to get out? Do you have to pee? Do you? Sorry, before we let you go, because we're rejecting that. What's on the docket for dinner tonight? Yeah.
是送外卖的到门口了吗？你得跑一趟吗？这就是你为什么想脱身的原因吗？你想去嘘嘘吗？是吗？抱歉，在我们放你走之前，因为我们要否决那个。今晚晚饭吃什么？对。
You'll love this. You'll love it. You'll love it. You'll love it. You'll love it. It's roasted chicken with vegetables. Gotti, what are we having for dinner? Oh, fuck.
你会喜欢的。你会喜欢的。你会喜欢的。你会喜欢的。你会喜欢的。是烤鸡配蔬菜。Gotti，我们晚饭吃什么？哦，操。
What else? And some other stuff. And like mashed potatoes. Oh, mashed potatoes. So like a full, well, basically like a holiday dinner tonight? Let's be honest. It actually does look like a holiday dinner. Let's be honest.
还有什么？还有别的东西。比如土豆泥。哦，土豆泥。所以就像一顿丰盛的，基本上就像今晚吃节日大餐一样？老实说。看起来确实像一顿节日大餐。老实说。
Is it chicken with mashed potatoes or is it mashed potatoes with chicken? And then what do we have? And then so no dessert, right? So I don't know. We'll probably have chocolate chip cookies. But listen, if I, once I'm done eating all of that and I have to leave the table, you know, because to eliminate. Because you can't eat another.
是鸡肉配土豆泥，还是土豆泥配鸡肉？然后我们还有什么？然后就没有甜点了吧？所以我不确定。我们大概会吃巧克力豆曲奇。但是听着，如果我，一旦我吃完了所有这些，我必须离开餐桌，你知道的，因为要去排泄。因为你吃不下了。
Bye. Bye. Yes. I don't want to be a loser myself. Yeah. I don't want to be a loser. Of course. Yes.
再见。再见。是的。我可不想自己变成个失败者。对。我不想当个失败者。当然。是的。
Yes. That's pathetic. Yeah. Smart. Lost. Smart. Lost. Smart.
是的。太可悲了。对。聪明。迷失。聪明。迷失。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbicow. Smart. Less. Smart.
迷失。SmartLess 是由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf 和 Bennett Barbicow 100% 有机且手工打造的。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. That's our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Less。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，也可以通过在苹果播客或 Wondry 应用上订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听且无广告。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。